Das war's für heute, wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Was macht ihr denn alle so schnell hier? Ich dachte, ich kann jetzt erst noch ein bisschen meinen Chat-Logs aufräumen und sonst was machen.
Normalerweise braucht Twitch immer eine ganze Weile, bis der Kram online geht.
Aber heute nicht. Wer ist denn am Start? Limitix. Oder Limitix? Ich weiß nicht.
Ähm, Matze2090, BrianL4 und der Vegas. Geh ich mal von aus, dass es Vegas heißt und nicht Wegwatz.
Was ist denn wieder mit den Benutzernamen und Zahlen drinne? Der Tobix ist am Start, Captain Seeker ist auch mal wieder da.
Exzellent.
Pünktlich wie immer, ja, ich sehs, ich sehs, Leute. PC Lustig ist da, Fer12 ist am Start.
So, ich zeig euch mal meinen Desktop, weil ich weiß, der Chat mag meinen Desktop besonders.
Der Chat guckt sich immer gerne meinen Desktop an. Das hab ich schon festgestellt.
Ich glaub, ich muss noch was zu trinken holen gleich.
Leute, ich kann den Desktop noch ein bisschen besser machen, wenn ihr wollt.
Ist besser? Ist das besser so?
Perfekt.
Bester Desktop EU. Manch einer würde vielleicht sagen NA Desktop, aber das stimmt nicht.
Monarch S.
Wir können doch mal das Gegenteil machen. Komm mal, wie viel Platz wir da noch haben drauf.
Ja, der Windows XP Hintergrund ist der beste.
Der Windows XP Hintergrund ist der beste. Ich wusste nicht, wie die Windows XP Wiese heute aussieht.
Das sieht überhaupt nicht mehr gut aus. Guck, so sieht die Windows XP Wiese heute aus.
So, guck. Das war die Windows XP Wiese zu Windows XP Zeiten. Das ist die Windows XP Wiese von heute.
Ey, wie bist du eigentlich auf den Namen Wupplos gekommen? Random, genauso wie ich in Call of Duty LUL HD heiße. Ich hab irgendwas eingetippt.
Das ist der schlechteste Wallpaper, den ich je gesehen hab.
Wer ist auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen, da ein U-Boot reinzumachen? Warum?
Ha, das war's net.
Naja, und eigentlich war der Account nie dafür da, dass ich selber streamen soll, aber irgendwann hab ich mir da gedacht, fängste doch an.
Dann hab ich den Account genommen. Eigentlich total bescheuert, aber so ist es.
So ist es.
So, was wir heute machen, ist folgendes, und zwar im letzten Stream. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob derjenige, der das gefragt hat, überhaupt da ist heute oder überhaupt noch kommt heute.
Keine Ahnung, und zwar im letzten Stream hat einer vorgeschlagen, wir könnten mal versuchen, ob wir CPU-Overlay programmieren können.
CPU-Temperatur und CPU- und GPU-Temperatur-Overlay programmieren können. Ich hab gedacht, das probieren wir mal aus.
Ich bin mir noch nicht so ganz sicher, wie wir das machen. Das Einzige, was ich im Vorfeld schon mal nachgeguckt hab, ist, wie man am besten unter Windows die CPU-Temperatur rausbekommt.
Und dreimal dürft ihr raten, wie man am besten unter Windows die CPU-Temperatur rausbekommt mit Bordmitteln.
Gar nicht.
Richtig.
Gar nicht. Also es gibt ein paar Tipps, wenn man beispielsweise Stack-Overflow dazu befragt.
So nach dem Motto, was kann ich haben, Stack-Overflow, CPU-Temperatur. Ah hier, jetzt haben wir schon eine Frage.
So, wenn man das hier ausführt, was die hier vorschlagen, wird man feststellen, ah, not supported.
Und dann denkt man erst mal, ah nee, das liegt bestimmt daran, dass es nicht als Administrator ausgeführt wurde.
Geht OBS wieder?
Ähm.
Geht nicht. So.
Wollen wir nicht noch weiter Mac OS anschauen? Ich muss euch was gestehen, Leute.
Ich hab die VM gelöscht, wo wir Mac OS gestern ausprobiert haben, weil die hat so viel Speicherplatz belegt, dass ich nur 8 GB frei hatte.
Und 8 GB war mir zu wenig.
Wenn wir das nochmal ausprobieren, dann probieren wir das in der VM aus, die auf meinem Windows läuft.
Nested-Virtualisierung war eh keine gute Idee.
Das probieren wir in der VM, ich installiere mir VirtualBox nochmal, dann probieren wir das aus.
Das schreibe ich dann aber auch extra in Titel rein.
Schreiben wir mal hier Mac OS VM, dann machen wir mal einen eigenen Stream.
Ja, Tanser, du hast nichts verpasst, wir haben 10 Minuten lang Mac OS zugeguckt, wie es sich installiert.
Die 10 Minuten gingen halt eineinhalb Stunden.
Das stand halt am Anfang, da dauert 10 Minuten, und ich glaube nach 50 Minuten waren wir dann bei 2 Minuten runter oder so.
Das war, äh, Paints-Champ.
Also, ich habe hier, wie ich hier gerade gesagt habe, also das, was man hier findet, unter Stack Overflow und alle möglich anderen Seiten, wie man angeblich mit Windows-Bordmitteln die CPU-Temperatur ausliest, geht nicht.
Geht nicht.
Und ich habe da mal ein bisschen nachgeguckt, woran das liegt.
Und, ähm, das ist folgendermaßen diese, diese, ähm, diese Windows, was heißt das, Windows-Messaging-Server, was heißt denn WMI eigentlich?
Was heißt denn das?
Windows-Management-Instrumentation, alles klar, exzellent benahme Microsoft.
Das muss das BIOS exportieren, das EFI exportieren, diese Werte, und das machen die wenigsten.
Alternativ kann das auch irgendeine Zusatzsoftware exportieren, aber das macht es standardmäßig nicht.
So, das heißt, es gibt unter Windows normal keinen Weg, die CPU-Temperatur rauszubekommen.
So, ohne weiteres.
Aber, wie ihr natürlich alle wisst, gibt es Möglichkeiten, weil es gibt Programme, die die CPU-Temperatur abfragen.
Also, das heißt, es muss eine Möglichkeit geben.
Und ich habe mal ein bisschen rumgeguckt im Vorfeld, ob man das nicht vielleicht selbst machen kann von Hand.
Wie kann das HW-Info dann?
Ja, da kommen wir gleich dazu.
Es gibt ja ein paar Programme, die das kennen.
Ich meine, CPU-Z zum Beispiel.
Wenn man sich das anguckt, da steht ja auch alles Mögliche dabei.
Ich weiß gar nicht, haben die Temperatur wahrscheinlich.
Also sprich, die können ja auch jede Menge Sachen aus der CPU auslesen, die so gar nicht möglich sind, über Windows abzufragen.
So, und ich habe mir gedacht, vielleicht können wir das richtig, richtig big brain machen.
Und wir können da quasi irgendwelche Register auslesen, vielleicht mit C oder vielleicht ein paar Assembler-Befäle oder sonst was.
Können wir Register auslesen.
Aber ich musste feststellen, es ist deutlich komplizierter, als ich mir das Ganze vorgestellt habe, aus einer CPU die Temperatur auszulesen.
Es ist extrem kompliziert.
Das hätte ich nicht für möglich gehalten.
Ich dachte eigentlich, es gibt irgendeinen extra Assembler-Befäl für Intel und für AMD.
Oder vielleicht auch irgendwie den einheitlichen mittlerweile Befehl, den du, den Instructions, die du absetzt.
Und dann landet in irgendeinem Register die Temperatur.
So habe ich mir das gedacht.
So, und das funktioniert aber so nicht.
Leider, leider, ja.
So, und nachdem das Ganze nicht funktioniert, habe ich mich mal auf die Suche gemacht.
Was gibt es denn da alles für Software, die das Ganze kann?
Und da bin ich auf ein paar Projekte, das ist ja das Schöne an GitHub, dass man mittlerweile relativ easy Zugriff hat auf Riesen-Riesen-Software-Quellen.
Core-Temp, ja, das habe ich auch geguckt.
Core-Temp, das ist ja auch so ein Ding, was gerne verwendet wird.
Das ist ja quasi das CPU-Set für...
So, Core-Temp macht es ja irgendwie.
Also es geht offensichtlich.
Und es gibt ja noch zig andere Programme, die das unter Windows machen können.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt noch keine Ahnung, ob Core-Temp irgendeine API hat.
Oh, cool.
Nice, wusste ich gar nicht.
Wusste ich gar nicht, dass die das auch haben.
Interessant.
Interessant, wusste ich gar nicht, dass die auch eine API haben.
Könnte man vielleicht auch mal ausprobieren, aber ich habe was viel Besseres gefunden.
Genau, HW-Monitor kennt man auch.
Es gibt hier auch jede Menge Anzeigen.
Also sprich, man sieht, es geht.
Es geht.
Also man bekommt das Ganze raus.
Und was ich da gefunden habe, ist nämlich ein Open-Hardware,
weiß nicht, wie der Kram weiter heißt.
Ach so.
Ja, Moment.
Nicht bei mir in den Repos, sondern AllGitHub.
Das hier habe ich gefunden.
Und das Problem damit ist, das ist sogar relativ aktuelles Projekt,
was zig Sachen auslesen kann.
Das kann nicht nur CPU auslesen.
Das kann auch GPU-Temperatur, CPU-Temperatur, Mainboard-Temperatur,
alle möglichen Sachen.
Das kann relativ viel auslesen.
Was da nun das Problem ist, dass soweit ich das in dem...
Hat er die Mac OS-VM wieder laufen?
Nee.
Kälmer habe ich nicht.
Ich werde das mal in der neuen VM starten.
Lieber mir auf dem Haus lesen.
Nested-Virtualisierung ist keine gute Idee.
Das funktioniert nicht richtig.
Ich entzellehme irgendwann mal VirtualBox und mache das da drin.
So, das Problem bei dem Projekt ist, man sieht schon,
die haben am ersten 760 Issues offen.
Und anscheinend ist die Hardware-Unterstützung in letzter Zeit
ein bisschen...
Lässt wohl ein bisschen zu wünschen übrig.
So.
Und dann habe ich einen Fork davon gefunden.
Das Ganze nennt sich nämlich typische Big Brain...
Big Brain Open Source-Benamung.
Also wenn es ein Open-Hardware-Monitor gibt,
gibt es natürlich auch ein lieberer Hardware-Monitor.
Was sonst?
Das wäre schon mal...
Logisch.
Genau, den da gibt es.
Das ist ein Fork davon.
Was ist denn das denn von Intel?
Ah, Kameras.
Okay.
Genau, das Ding gibt es.
Das ist ein Fork von Open...
Schreiben Sie das so hin.
Ein Fork von Open-Hardware-Monitor.
Mit modernerer...
Also mit neuerer Hardware-Unterstützung.
Und wohl auch einigen neuen Features.
Und das werden wir benutzen.
Und das Gute ist, das Tolle und Praktische daran ist,
wir müssen gar keine Low-Level-Interop-Geschichten machen,
weil die bieten eine fix und fertige.NET-Library an,
um auf alles zuzugreifen, was diese Software kann.
Das ist extrem Big Brain.
Wir können uns jetzt erst mal angucken, was die Software kann.
Und dann, wie man das Ganze über die API auslesen.
Ich entpacke das mal.
Das müssen wir uns gerade mal angucken.
Haben wir hier irgendwie...
HW.
Ist ja nett von denen.
Ja.
Es ist vor allem C++++.
Haben wir ja gestern gelernt.
So, gucken wir uns das Ganze mal an, was das kann.
Ehrlich gesagt, die Software selbst habe ich noch nie verwendet.
Das sieht wahrscheinlich übelst hässlich aus jetzt.
Oh, Monkeys.
Ja.
Falls ihr mal sowas kriegt,
das ist Big Brain Logik von Windows.
Wenn du das startest
und die Software noch nicht vertrauenswürdig genug ist
aus Microsofts Sicht,
dann zeigen die einem dieses Popup hier an.
Das hat übrigens nichts damit zu tun,
dass die Anwendung gefährlich wäre
oder dass die Anwendung nicht signiert wäre.
Wenn die Anwendung oft genug runtergeladen wird
und gestartet wird, dann geht das automatisch.
Die haben im Hintergrund bei sich so eine Datenbank,
wo die quasi gucken,
wie die Excel im Endeffekt kennen wird, ist executable.
Hallo?
Aber man darf auch nichts anderes mal anklicken in der Zwischenzeit.
Und dann geht das automatisch.
Also das heißt nicht, dass es gefährlich ist.
Da geht man nämlich einfach auf More und sagt Run anyway und fertig.
Und da hat man den Open Hardware Monitor.
Man sieht, der kann CPU Temperatur abfragen.
Was auch immer das hier ist.
Wahrscheinlich der Chipsatz oder so.
Der erkennt sogar, was ich für Mainboard drinne hab.
Der erkennt meine Lüftergeschwindigkeit,
Lüfterauslastung, Lüfterauslastung, Geschwindigkeit,
CPU Core Auslastung.
Ich vermute mal, dass da ist der Core,
auf dem gerade OBS rendert.
Das kann nicht sein.
Die Temperatur ist viel zu hoch.
Warum ist denn die so hoch?
95 Grad, das ist glaube ich nicht ganz richtig.
Selbst nicht für das Ding, was...
Also 95 Grad erscheint mir unrealistisch hoch.
Und darunter dann 15 Grad.
Nee, das ist nicht so ganz richtig, würde ich sagen.
Hast du einen Ryzen? Nee.
Also das scheint nicht zu stimmen.
Sechs Kerne ist allerdings richtig.
Das hier trifft es eher.
Das hier trifft es eher, 57 Grad.
Wir gucken mal, was die AP gleich sagt.
Hier, guck mal, das sieht deutlich realistischer aus.
Ah, ich verstehe, guck mal.
Das ist das, was das Mainboard meint,
was die CPU für eine Temperatur hat.
Und das ist die Readings direkt von der CPU.
Oder?
Oder ist das die Temperatur vom Mainboard?
Nee, das ist die Temperatur vom Mainboard.
Das ist die Temperatur vom Mainboard.
Sprich, die Temperatursensor auf dem Mainboard drauf.
Exzellent.
Ist natürlich ein bisschen verwirrend gemacht,
also das interessiert uns gar nicht.
Also man sieht, er kann sogar den Clock-Speed auslesen.
Und auch die CPU-Temperaturen.
Das ist das, was uns interessiert hier.
CPU Core 1 bis CPU Core 6.
Und was uns da noch interessiert ist
GPU, Core, äh, Temperature, das da.
Zwölf Grad?
Wahrscheinlich gibt es den Sensor einfach gar nicht.
Ich vermute mal, der Sensor hier,
der wird immer statische Wert, der wird sich nie ändern.
Die Sensoren sind wahrscheinlich in der Firmware irgendwie drin,
aber die sind gar nicht angeschlossen.
Das heißt, die liefern irgendwie einen hardcoded Wert.
Warum auf meinem Mainboard irgendwas 96 Grad ist, weiß ich nicht,
aber ist mir auch egal.
Solange es funktioniert, ist alles in Ordnung.
Ja, und ihr seht, es kann wirklich extrem viel Zeug auslesen,
hardwaremäßig, was man hat.
Und das ist das Tool, was wir verwenden werden.
Allerdings nicht das fertige Tool.
Das wäre irgendwie langweilig, wenn man das Tool starten müsste,
dass man das Overlay starten kann.
Nee.
Die sind sehr nett und liefern hier eine...
Guck mal, das gibt es als Nougat-Package?
Wusste ich auch noch gar nicht.
Die liefern hier eine libre Hardware-Monitor lib mit.
Und das ist eine.NET DLL.
Die können wir direkt in unsere Anwendung einbinden und Sachen abfragen.
Das heißt, wir brauchen jetzt im Endeffekt
zwei oder drei verschiedene Komponenten für das Ganze.
Das ist Nougat-Package.
NuPKG.
Deswegen muss ich mal gucken, ob das nicht sogar auf Nougat verfügbar ist.
Das ist der Paket-Manager, der.NET Paket-Manager.
Also, Sie brauchen wahrscheinlich mindestens zwei Einheiten für das Programm.
Wir brauchen erstens eine WPF-Overlay.
Wir machen das mit WPF, weil UVP nicht praktikabel.
Windows Forms sackt für Transparenz.
Und die einzige Sache, die da übrig bleibt, die zwar auch uralt ist,
aber noch am besten funktioniert, ist UVP.
Das heißt, wir machen in den UVP-Overlay im Prinzip das Gleiche,
was man hier mit den Bildchen macht.
Ja, und das ist also das erste, was wir brauchen.
So, genau, das ist das erste, was wir brauchen.
Soll das Programm erst mal nur die Temperaturen anzeigen?
Ja, das war das, was derjenige im Stream gefragt hat.
Das ist erst mal das, was wir machen werden.
Ich glaube nicht, dass da am Ende was rauskommt, wo man sagen würde,
ja, das ist besser als MSI Afterburner oder sowas.
Also, wenn man wirklich ernsthaft sowas braucht,
dann wird man wahrscheinlich weiter die Programme nehmen,
die auch deutlich mehr Features haben.
Aber es ist trotzdem ganz interessant, denke ich, zu gucken,
wie man sowas machen kann.
FPS-Overlay kriege ich nicht raus.
FPS-Overlay bräuchte man irgendeinen DirectX OpenGL-Hook,
was dann wieder irgendwelche Anti-Cheat-Software erkennen würde.
Das ist wenig praktikabel.
Außerdem ist es viel komplizierter.
Sonst gibt man die FPS relativ schlecht raus.
Was ist die Motivation hinter dem Projekt,
zu gucken, wie es funktioniert?
Wie immer.
Also, genau, man braucht einen WPF-Overlay,
wo man durchklicken kann und transparent.
Transparent mit Text.
Das können wir uns klauen von hier, von meinem Memboard.
Können wir uns das abgucken, wie ich das da gemacht habe
und im Endeffekt einfach nochmal machen.
Und was geht es gerade?
Wir machen das, was letztens einer im Stream gefragt hat,
wo ich schon gesagt habe, dass es eine gute Idee für einen Stream ist.
Nämlich das hier.
Ein Programm, was CPU und GPU-Temperatur
als Overlay anzeigen kann.
Das waren wir heute.
Genau, das ist das erste, was wir brauchen.
Das zweite ist, und das ist wahrscheinlich eventuell,
je nachdem, wie das funktioniert, sogar das Kompliziertere.
Ach, da ist er ja.
Chill im Eck.
Er kommt auch am Start.
Du wolltest das wissen, oder?
War das nicht sogar von dir der Vorschlag?
Ah, ja, gut.
Da kannst du ja angucken, wie ich das Ganze machen würde.
Wie gesagt, es gibt zwar viel mehr Features,
die man noch einbauen könnte.
Zum Beispiel, welche Farbe der Text haben soll,
was man für Informationen hat, ein Optionsmenü,
welches man haben will, ob man alle CPU-Cores auf einmal haben will
oder jede CPU-Core getrennt oder was auch immer.
Nur mal so, wie man es machen könnte.
So, und das zweite ist, ja, halt CPU, CPU-GPU-Temp,
Temp-Auslesen mit Libre-Hardware-Monitor,
oder wie das Ding heißt.
Ich würde sagen, damit fangen wir auch an.
Und ich gucke gerade mal, ob das vielleicht wirklich
mittlerweile als Nougat-Package da ist.
Ich habe heute versucht, eine DLL in Notepad zu injecten
und bin kläglich gescheitert, schreibt ShoesbyName.
Warum genau wolltest du eine DLL in Notepad injecten?
Für Linux gibt es zig Geschichten, ja, von...
Wie heißt das? Ah, wir...
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Es gibt so ein ganz bekanntes Overlay für Linux.
Ey, fällt mir aber gerade der Name nicht ein.
War das nicht Dietzen oder so? War das nicht so was?
Ne, das bringe ich durcheinander.
Das bringe ich durcheinander.
Das hier neben meine ich.
Och ja.
Aja ja.
Heute Morgen hat sich übrigens meine Katze richtig
pro wie sie ist versteckt.
Also ich bin mir nicht sicher, Leute, ob ihr überhaupt die Katze erkennt auf dem Bild.
Ich finde ja, eigentlich sieht man nix.
Gonky meine ich genau, Selfmade Eyes.
Also ich sehe die Katze nicht.
Der Teppich, ich sehe nur einen Teppich.
Wieso liegt da ein T-Shirt?
Das liegt da, weil die irgendwie gerne sich unter meinem T-Shirt versteckt.
Cobol. Ach Gott, hör mal auf.
Du willst mich echt quälen mit dem Cobol Zeug.
Okay, ich würde sagen, wir machen mal, wir machen mal.
Komm, wir machen schon mal ein WPF Projekt.
Da haben wir schon mal ein Fenster am Start, wo wir was anzeigen können.
WPF. Kann man eigentlich mittlerweile ordentlich eine WPF Anwendung machen?
Mit.NET Core geht das jetzt eigentlich mittlerweile halbwegs gescheit.
Habe ich glaube ich noch nie gemacht.
Habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Müsste eigentlich mittlerweile ganz gut funktionieren.
Hast du das OSX Zeug noch gemacht?
Nee, das ist nicht fertig geworden.
Ich werde das auch anders machen.
Ich werde das nicht nested virtualisiert machen.
Ich installiere mir für einen der nächsten Streams installiere ich mir einfach Virtualbox
und dann probieren wir es aus.
Ohne nested Virtualisierung.
Dann läuft es wahrscheinlich auch schneller und man kann es verwenden.
Okay, wir brauchen einen guten Namen für das Ding.
Ihr wisst ja, ich bin immer wahnsinnig kreativ.
Was Benamung von Projekten angeht.
Also wenn mir nichts einfällt.
Normalerweise, wenn ich das jetzt nicht im Stream machen würde, dann würde ich das
den WPF App 2 nennen.
Was?
Oh nee, das kann keiner aussprechen.
Max Monitor.
Die Idee ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Max.
Max Monitor.
Nee, das ist doof.
Es gibt immer noch keinen vernünftigen Designer.
Ah, Designer braucht man nicht.
Einfach nur Monitor.
Max GPU.
Das finde ich eine gute Idee.
Es gibt zwar überhaupt keinen Sinn, dass es so heiß auf den Namen geht.
Top Keg.
Max GPU finde ich irgendwie gut.
Der Name ergibt zwar nicht wirklich viel Sinn.
Temp Keg.
Temp Keg finde ich gut.
Temp Keg gefällt mir fast noch besser.
Oder Keg Temp.
Was ist besser Keg Temp oder Temp Keg?
Temp Keg.
Temp ist gut, das steht am Anfang.
Dann findet man es auch besser.
Temp Keg.
Exzellent.
Nicht was Non-Subs sagen.
Es gibt ganz einfache Möglichkeiten.
Es müssen einfach alle Non-Subs werden.
Dann ist es wieder okay.
Okay, der Designer muss weg.
Der Designer muss schnellstens weg.
Ich kriege Anfälle, wenn ich den Designer sehe.
View-Code.
Okay, exzellent.
Der Designer muss weg.
Ich mag den nicht.
Habe ich jetzt eigentlich...
Habe ich jetzt Wishlist-Studio 2019?
Ist es 19?
Ja.
Ja, ist 19.
Ich habe mich verwirrt, weil ich habe noch 2017 drauf.
Sonst findet man immer nur die 251 Programme,
die mit Keg anfangen bei dir.
Ja, da gibt es ein paar.
Okay, das Erste, was wir machen, ist,
wir stellen mal um,
dass wir keine Windows-Anwendung machen,
sondern eine Konsolen-Anwendung.
Wir machen ja eine Windows-Anwendung,
aber für Debug-Zwecke ist es besser,
wenn auch eine Konsolen-Anwendung mit am Start ist.
Gut.
Ähm...
Ja, dann probieren wir das Ganze doch mal aus.
Also, wir verwenden, wie gesagt,
diese libre Hardware-Monitor lib.
Das heißt, wir adden das Ganze mal als Library.
Und dann gucken wir mal,
ob wir es schaffen, die CPU-Temperatur auslesen.
Liest du das dann per Konsole oder GUI aus?
Äh, wie denn noch?
Ich lese das über die Hardware-Monitor-Library aus.
Anzeigen tue ich es erst mal in der Konsole,
und wenn das alles funktioniert,
zeige ich es im Fenster an.
Ich meine, in den Konsolen-Overlay funktioniert ja nicht wirklich.
So.
Ach, stimmt, ich wollte gucken,
ob es über Nougat gibt, genau.
Ähm...
Moment, wie hieß der Kram hier?
Libre Hardware-Monitor lib.
Der Name ist irgendwie ein bisschen lang, oder?
Ey!
Cool.
Tatsächlich.
Das ist aber irgendwas anderes, ha?
Nee, das ist das.
Interessant, dass es mittlerweile sogar über Nougat geht.
Schon mal passiert, dass ein PC überhitzt ist, ja?
Klar.
Das kommt relativ oft vor.
Oh, der Tanser geht wieder ab.
Schon wieder neue 5 Abos.
Poggers.
Wer wurde denn heute beglückt?
Ähm...
Wen haben wir denn hier?
Diddy Holz kriegt einen Subscriber.
Es gibt... kriegt eine Subscription.
Churro kriegt auch eine...
Schäkel Shovel kriegt einen.
Dreixent kriegt einen und Obst...
Obst... Lauflau... Ach, Obstauflauf.
Ah, exzellent. Aussprache. Exquisite.
Huge. Sehr nice.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, das kommt vor, dass PCs überhitzen.
Das kommt relativ häufig sogar vor.
Warum haben wir hier einen Apple Event auf?
Das haben wir uns anscheinend mal angeguckt, glaube ich.
Das brauchen wir nicht mehr.
Oh, okay, das nehmen wir doch nicht. Das Projekt, das ist zu alt.
Na toll.
Exzellent.
Schön, dass ihr den Kram aktualisiert.
Weil die Library selbst, die ist neu.
Dann müssen wir sie doch hinzufügen.
Dann gibt es doch keinen Nugget Package für.
Okay, Dependencies. Add Dependencies.
Und zwar diese Library hier. Wo haben wir sie?
Browse.
Okay.
Da ist sie.
Natürlich habe ich mir den Kram im Vorfeld mal kurz angeguckt, was man da alles machen kann.
Ach so, was wir noch machen müssen, ist, wir müssen einstellen, dass der Kram...
Wahrscheinlich müssen wir einstellen, dass der Kram mitkopiert wird.
Ne, müssen wir nicht.
Das ist ja alles, landet ja alles automatisch in der Exe drin. Müssen wir gar nicht.
Da macht das alles automatisch für uns. Das passt schon.
Patrick, was haben wir... Hä?
Wo ist das Problem? Sie juckt doch überhaupt nicht.
Wenn du sobald du das bildest, ist die Datei noch mit dabei.
Ich meine, klar, wenn ich den anderen Ordner lösche, ist es kaputt, aber who cares.
Ja, wobei, ja, ist doch besser, ist doch besser. Warte mal, ich mache es mal weg.
Ja, hast recht, ist doch sinniger.
Ist doch sinniger, dass sie irgendwo hier in den Ordner rein zu kopieren, das stimmt.
Kopieren wir es doch mal hier rein.
Ne, so advanced sind wir nicht, wir machen das hier einfach in den Ordner rein.
Welchem Ordner sind wir denn jetzt hier? Topkirk.
Da.
So, jetzt aber.
So, ich habe mir im Vorfeld schon ein bisschen angeguckt, wie der Kram funktioniert,
weil ich komplett planlos bin. Also das Ding hat ein paar Namespaces, die man brauchen.
Und wer hätte das gedacht, die fangen mit Liebere-Hardware-Monitor an.
In den Windows Tempor, das ist auch eine gute Idee. Hardware.
So, die Sachen brauchen wir. Und was man dann machen kann, ist, wir machen...
Wir können es mal so machen, wir zeigen, wir schreiben erst die Sachen in die Konsole,
wenn die Sache angezeigt wird.
Oh je, WPF-Events, Leute. Ich mache so selten WPF.
On, Open, Show. Was ist das Event in WPF, wenn die Form angezeigt wird?
Visible? Ne.
Wie geht das in WPF? On. Was ist das Event? On Closing? On Content Changed? On Activated.
On Activated. Das klingt gut. Gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert.
Eins. Entschuldigt, Konsolen-Debugging, so wie man es macht.
Ah ja, okay, das funktioniert. On Load gibt es auch noch.
On Load? Ah, da ist das IntelliSense wieder kaputt.
Muss man sagen, in diesem Bereich ist... Ne, On Load gibt es nicht.
Ist Ryder wirklich besser? Die können sowas.
On Activated ist okay, passt. Kann nicht mitleben.
So, und jetzt probieren wir mal, die CPU-Temperatur auszulesen.
Activated ist doch, wenn das Fenster Fokus bekommt. Das können wir mal ausprobieren.
Ne, ich glaube, Activated ist, wenn sie gesta...
Ach so, vielleicht soll ich die Ausgabe wieder reinmachen.
Ja, okay, das ist, wenn es Fokus bekommt. Ist okay, kann nicht mitleben.
Also, jetzt versuchen wir mal, den Kram auszulesen, ob das funktioniert.
Und ich habe ja im Vorfeld schon ein bisschen nachgeguckt, wie das funktioniert.
Die API von dem Ding ist ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Aber trotzdem relativ easy. Also, man kann hier sagen...
Computer, das heißt wirklich so.
Komm, ich kann nicht schreiben.
Computer gleich New, Computer.
Komm, wenn man es richtig schreibt, dann geht das auch.
Weiß gar nicht, was ist da für Settings, braucht man nicht.
So, und dann sagt Computer. Das habe ich im Vorfeld abgeguckt.
Ähm...
Das habe ich irgendwo auf Stackoverflow gefunden.
Ich frage mich nicht, ob das richtig ist, aber ich hoffe mal, es funktioniert.
So, und dann sagt man Open. Open.
Und dann kann man eine Vorschleife machen über die gesamte Hardware, die das Ding erkennt.
Also, die diese Library erkennt.
Das ist eigentlich recht easy. So, und dann kann man sich ausgeben lassen.
Hardware, Name.
Also sprich, da können wir uns alles auflisten lassen, was diese Library jetzt erkannt hat.
So, mal gucken, was Sache ist.
Es crasht schon mal, das ist schon mal wunderbar.
Excellent.
Enemy easy, not dirty at all!
Ah.
Ah, could not load file or assembly system management. Okay.
Das heißt, wir haben eine Abhängigkeit, die das Ding braucht.
Wäre das jetzt natürlich ein ordentliches Nougat-Package, dann würde die Abhängigkeit automatisch aufgelöst.
Aber das ist ja zu advanced dafür.
Da, system management, install.
Okay.
So, hoffentlich geht's jetzt.
Ah, wow.
Das ist Mario Kart auf jeden Fall.
Das sieht nach hinten...
Ist die letzte Version verbackt?
Hm.
Ah!
Die Library brauche ich.
Die brauche ich, das ist... Ah!
Ich vermute also, ich vermute mal.
Das ist definitiv Mario Kart.
Das ist Mario Kart 64 Rainbow Road.
Ich vermute mal, die Library, die hier liegt, ist eine normale.NET Framework Library.
Und die Library, die hier liegt, ist eine.NET Standard Library.
Und wir brauchen die.NET Standard Library, weil.NET Standard 2 in.NET Core drin ist.
Und hier werden Sie Sachen verwenden aus dem normalen.NET Framework.
Was übrigens mit.NET 5 wieder richtig Microsoft Big Brain wird.
Ich habe es ja schon ein paar Mal erzählt, aber das kann man nicht oft genug erzählen.
Die aktuelle Version des.NET Frameworks ist ja Version 4.8.
Die aktuelle.NET Core Version ist 3.1 oder 3.2.
Keine Ahnung, 3.1 glaube ich.
Und man muss wissen, dass.NET Core das Neue ist von Microsoft und.NET Framework eigentlich nicht mehr richtig unterstützt wird.
Also sprich, die kleinere Version mit dem Wort Core davor ist eigentlich die viel neuere und bessere und kann auch mehr.
Und hat auch viele neue Features, die das.NET Framework gar nicht hat.
So, und jetzt kommt Microsoft auf die glorreiche Idee.
Achso, für die Frage an den Chat, ihr wisst wahrscheinlich.
Was meint ihr jetzt, wie die nächste.NET Core Version heißen wird?
Was meint ihr, wie wird die nächste.NET Core Version heißen?
Kawaii Shock sagt 5, genau.
Die heißt dann allerdings nicht mehr.NET Core 5, sondern die heißt dann nur noch.NET 5.
Was die Verwirrung letztendlich komplett machen wird.
Weil.NET 5 ist nicht etwa der Nachfolger des.NET Frameworks 4.8, was man eigentlich denken würde bei der Benamung,
sondern.NET 5 ist der Nachfolger von.NET Core 3.1.
Der Sinn dahinter ist, sie wollen quasi.NET Framework und.NET Core nicht mehr haben.
Sie sagen jetzt mit.NET 5 ist das alles unter einer Haube.
Aber die Benamung wird es noch viel komplizierter machen.
Zumal es einige andere Produkte von Microsoft gibt.
Zum Beispiel das Entity Framework.
Das ist die Datenbank-Management-Schnittstelle.
Das Entity Framework heißt Entity Framework Core, kurz abgekürzt EF Core.
Was aktuell auch immer die gleiche Version hat wie die.NET Core Version.
Und da wird es spannend.
Da wird das Namenschaos komplett.
Was machen sie jetzt?
Nennen sie das Entity Framework 5.
Das würde dann zu.NET 5 passen.
Nennen sie es Entity Framework Core 5.
Dann ist auf einmal wieder ein Core da.
Allerdings in der Runtime ist das Core weg.
Was die Sache noch viel komplizierter macht ist,
dass es vor Entity Framework Core ein Entity Framework von Microsoft gab.
Und da war die letzte Version glaube ich 6.
Alles klar, oder?
Das heißt wir bekommen jetzt eine neue Runtime, die.NET 5 heißt.
Die nichts mit 4.8 zu tun hat.
Sondern.NET Core 3 quasi Nachfolger ist.
Und wir bekommen ein Entity Framework Core, was eventuell Core heißt.
Was nicht mehr zur Runtime passt.
Und eine niedrige Versionsnummer hat als das eigentliche Entity Framework,
was vor 8 Jahren aktualisiert wurde.
Exzellent, Microsoft.
Exzellent, alles klar.
Big Brain.
Monarch S.
Also Microsoft ist wirklich sehr gut da drinnen,
Dinge verwirrend zu benennen.
Oh by the way, ich sehs gerade, Tazer schreibts gerade im Chat.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, das mir gerade eingefallen.
Microsoft ist ja auch der Meinung, dass Office 365 nicht mehr Office 365 heißen soll.
Jetzt gerade wo sich die ganze Welt dran gewöhnt hat,
dass Office 365,
dass Office 365 heißt,
wird das ganze umbenannt in Microsoft 365.
Also eins kann Microsoft echt nicht, das ist Sachen benennen.
Ja.
Wieso nicht einfach Office? Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Also da müssen schon ausgesprochene,
massive, big, highest IQ Leute sitzen bei Microsoft,
die sich die Namen ausdenken.
Da sind übrigens auch die gleichen Leute,
die gesagt haben, dass Xbox Scarlet sich nicht gut genug anhört wahrscheinlich
und deswegen das Ding jetzt irgendwie heißen muss,
dass ich mir nicht mehr merken kann, wie es heißt.
Leute, ich denk's mir nicht aus,
ich habe keine Ahnung, wie die neue Xbox heißen wird.
Ich glaube Xbox Series X.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Wirklich, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Xbox Scarlet konnte man sich so gut merken
und ich fand es Scarlet, ich hab's schon 20.000 Mal gesagt,
das war der beste Name,
den sie hätten geben können ihrer Konsole.
Xbox Scarlet, das geht so schön von den Lippen,
das ist auch mal was nicht ausgelutschtes vom Namen her.
Es ist auch was Klangvolles.
Dann hat man so was wie Xbox Scarlet
und macht daraus Xbox Series X.
Weil Microsoft.
Aber mit Benamung hat's Microsoft ja prinzipiell nicht so.
Das haben wir ja schon gelernt.
Ich lösche den Kram hier gerade mal.
Das ist nämlich komplett die falsche Library,
die wir hier referenziert haben.
Das ist Kirby Musik.
Poggers.
Gibt es auch noch Windows Core OS?
Oh je, das hätten wir noch gefehlt.
Das hätte jetzt echt noch gefehlt.
Ich trau denen alles zu.
Ich hab's Ende letzten Jahres gesagt.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass Microsoft sich die Gelegenheit entgehen lässt,
im Jahr 2020 irgendwie eine neue Windows Version rauszubringen.
Aber anscheinend doch.
Die haben jetzt ihr komisches Windows X,
wo man nicht so genau weiß, was es im Endeffekt werden wird.
Aber ich hätte drauf wetten können Ende letzten Jahres,
dass dieses Jahr ein neues Windows angekündigt wird.
Oder zumindest irgendwie ein großer Patch mit Rename angekündigt wird,
dass das Ding jetzt Windows X heißt oder Windows 20 oder so.
Weil laut Microsoft-Logik wäre das richtig sinnvoll gewesen.
Nach Windows 10 kommt Windows 20.
Das wäre richtig Big Brain gewesen von Microsoft.
So nach dem Motto, wir zählen jetzt einfach die 10er-Stellen hoch.
Weil den anderen Kram kann sich eh keiner mehr merken.
Es kommt jetzt Windows 10, dann kommt Windows 20,
und als nächstes kommt dann Windows 25.
Die hätten es einfach nach dem Jahr benennen sollen und gut ist.
Was auch immer.
Hab ich jetzt eigentlich das Richtige kopiert?
.NET Standard wollte ich kopieren.
Replace.
Excellent.
Ja, natürlich könnten Sie es auch in Römisch machen.
So, also Dependencies hinzufügen.
Oh, nee, nee, warte mal, hab ich das Richtige angek...
Geh fort, ich hab die verklickt.
Project Reference Browse.
Exquisite.
Da ist es.
Okay.
Und jetzt sollte es laufen, wenn ich die richtige Library drin hab.
Ah, Poggers. Okay, funktioniert, Leute.
Funktioniert, es startet.
So, aber er erkennt keine Hardware.
Warum erkennt er keine Hardware?
Er sollte eigentlich, eigentlich sollte er Hardware erkennen.
Er erkennt keine Hardware.
Sollte er aber hier, sollte er mal eine ganze Hardware ausgeben.
Vielleicht muss man das irgendwie anders verwenden.
Computer, Punkt.
Ah, Computer Stop, ja.
Oder Close oder so.
Muss man auch hinten noch dran machen, wahrscheinlich.
Aber das ist ja vorher egal.
Das müsste eigentlich...
Hab gerade zugestellt, was programmiert.
Wir basteln ein Overlay mit CPU und GPU Temperatur.
Weil es hat letztens jemand im Stream gefragt, ob ich wüsste, wie sowas geht.
Und da hab ich mir gedacht, das ist eigentlich eine ziemlich gute Idee für den Stream.
Das ist recht übersichtlich, geht schnell.
Und ich kann mal selbst gucken, wie der Kram funktioniert.
Und ich hab festgestellt vor dem Stream, dass es viel komplizierter ist, als ich gedacht hätte,
unter Windows die CPU Temperatur auszulesen.
So, also was gibt's denn hier sonst noch? Computers.
Hardware added, removed.
Is controller enabled? Ist CPU enabled?
Ich hoffe mal, dass meine CPU enabled ist.
Und ich hoffe auch, dass meine GPU enabled ist.
Ah, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich glaube, das sind Parameter.
Ich glaube, das sind Parameter, wenn ich die setze.
Das hab ich, glaube ich, im Beispiel vorher auch gesehen.
Nur dann fragt er die Sachen ab.
Okay, sagen wir mal, ist CPU enabled?
Ah, guck mal. Intel Core i7-8700K.
Funktioniert. Hardware auslesen. Excellent. Nice.
Okay. Und wie kommen wir jetzt an die Temperatur dran?
Also hier haben wir die CPU drinne.
Hardware.
Sensors. Sensors klingt gut.
Sensors gibt einen iSensorArray. Alles klar.
Aber nochmal for each.
Sensor in Sensors.
Und dann geben wir nochmal den Sensorname aus.
Schauen wir mal, was es da gibt.
Das Fenster geht mir auf den Keks. Ah, guck mal.
Was haben wir hier zur Auswahl?
CPU Core 1, CPU Core 2, CPU Core 1 oder?
CPU Package, CPU Core Distance, Core Max, CPU Core...
Okay, ich würd sagen, damit kann man was anfangen.
Gibt's nicht eigentlich auch ein WMI-Objekt für die CPU-Temperatur?
Nein. Nichts, was zuverlässig funktioniert.
Es gibt zwar eine Namespace oder auch ein Objekt, ein WMI-Objekt gibt es.
Allerdings ist das abhängig davon, ob das BIOS, EFI, was auch immer.
Das unterstützt und die meisten unterstützen es nicht.
Zum Beispiel mein Mainboard unterstützt das nicht.
Also sprich da drüber, kriegst du es gar nicht raus.
Es gibt dafür was, aber es funktioniert nicht zuverlässig.
Wenn du Glück hast, funktioniert es vielleicht auf deinem Rechner.
Aber bei mir sagt es zum Beispiel nicht supported.
Bei anderen sagt es genau, das hab ich auf Stack Overflow auch gelesen.
Bei manchen sagt es eine feste Temperatur.
Und bei manchen funktioniert es.
So, dann geben wir nochmal den Sensor.
Sensor, was haben wir da sonst noch?
Sensor...
Sensor, was haben wir da noch?
Parameter, Sensor Type ist wahrscheinlich noch ganz interessant.
Das werden wir noch brauchen.
Und Sensor Values.
Values brauchen wir auf jeden Fall.
Und wisst ihr was, ich mach den ganzen Kram...
...doch mal da oben rein.
Dann kommt es nur einmal.
So, also sprich wir sollten jetzt eine Ausgabe kriegen.
Hier guck mal, damit kann man doch was anfangen.
Damit kann man doch richtig was anfangen.
Ist das Stream noch abrufbar, wo du Arschlucks einrichtest?
Gestern war das noch.
Das war der letzte Stream, der verfügbar ist.
War mir auf dem Channel noch.
Wenn nicht im Archiv, ist er bestimmt noch drinne, wenn du im Archiv guckst.
Oder wobei, weiß nicht, ob es der Sebaro schon ins Archiv gemacht hat.
Keine Ahnung.
Wumlords.tv
Haben wir, und da gibt es irgendwo einen Archiv Knopf.
Gucken wir mal, ob das da drinne ist.
2020.
Oh guck mal, wir haben sogar eine Search TXT.
Dann können wir damit.
Das könnte der gewesen sein hier.
Manjaro Linux perfekt vom Scratch einrichten.
Das könnte der gewesen sein.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist der hier.
Also der müsste im Archiv hier...
Wow, nein, nein, nein.
Ich will nicht den kompletten Ordner runterladen.
Der müsste also hier drinne stehen.
Musst du mal durchgucken.
Der sollte im Archiv drinne sein.
Hier, da ist er doch.
Da ist doch der Stream.
Richtig Big Brain vom Sebaro wieder.
Guck, hier wird Zeug eingerichtet.
Und Wodafone spackt herum.
Und es wird Paprika gemacht.
Okay, also damit können wir doch schon mal was anfangen.
CPU Core Load.
Load interessiert mich überhaupt nicht.
Temperature.
Okay, CPU Core Temperature 76.
Ja, ist das Grad?
Ist das, ist das Grad, ist das...
Na gut, Fahrenheit, was auch immer.
Ja, es wird wahrscheinlich Grad sein.
Kelvin, genau.
Das wäre aber ganz schön kalt.
CPU Graphics Power gibt es nicht.
CPU Memory Power.
Guck mal, man kriegt sogar die Spannung raus.
Das ist echt praktisch.
Nice, okay.
Das heißt, wir gucken jetzt mal,
dass wir nur die Temperature Sensors rauskriegen.
Also, Select nur die Sensors mit Type gleich Temperature.
Ach nee, grad nicht Select.
Oh ja, was mache ich da für einen Blödsinn?
Genau, jetzt haben wir nämlich nur die Temperatur von der CPU drin.
Nutzt du zwei Spaces zum Einholen?
Ja.
Ich machte seit einer Weile schon mit zwei Spaces.
Es geht natürlich nur was, wo ich alleine dran bastel
oder man sich vorher darauf geeinigt hat.
Ich finde, das spart einfach massig Eindrückungstiefe
und man kann die Sache besser lesen.
Vier White Spaces ist auch okay.
Gut, das heißt, wir können jetzt schon mal
die CPU Temperatur auslesen.
Das ging einfacher, als ich mir das Ganze vorgestellt habe hier.
CPU Core Temperature 1, okay.
Ich würde sagen, wir beschränken uns erst mal drauf,
so einen Mittelwert aus allen CPU-Kernen auszulesen.
Was hältst du von Overclocking?
Das ist eine sinnvolle Sache.
Wenn man das passende Board und vor allem den passenden CPU-Kühler hat,
ist das eine sinnvolle Geschichte.
Vor allem bei Intel-CPUs, weil was man bei Intel-CPUs immer machen kann,
ohne großartig zu übertacken, was aber auch schon ganz gut was bringt, ist,
du kannst im BIOS oder im EFI den All-Core-Turbo einschalten.
Also sprich, dass alle Kerne Unterlast immer bis zum maximalen Boost-Takt gehen.
Und den maximalen Boost-Takt müssen sie aushalten.
Ansonsten taktet es halt nicht so hoch, wenn alle Kerne ausgelastet sind.
Also ich habe meine CPU, das sind 8700K, übertaktet.
Also er geht auf maximal 5,1 GHz.
Da muss ich aber ziemlich viel Spannung draufhauen.
Und jetzt habe ich ihn ein bisschen weiter runtergetaktet.
Also nein, nicht so weit hochgetaktet wie 5,1.
Irgendwelche Tipps will ich ja in 50 Milliarden.
Das ist eine Sache, das muss jeder Kerl selbst rauskriegen.
Wie er seinen Baden wachsen lassen will.
Macht ihr doch den Commander-Krieger-Bad.
Also wir kriegen jetzt alle Temperatursensoren raus.
Und wir brauchen ja nicht alle.
Heute Morpheus, nee, warum soll ich den machen?
Ich weiß ja, wie er ausgeht.
Also CPU, Temperature, Temperature.
Okay, wir müssen jetzt mal die richtigen Sensorwerte rausholen.
Also wir wollen die Werte CPU Core 1 bis CPU Core 6.
Das werde ich jetzt einfach mal hardcoden.
Weil ich keinen Bock habe, das anders zu machen und mir gerade nichts anderes da einfällt.
Also, so, da waren wir jetzt mal in IF.
Und gucken nach, wenn der Name vom Sensor contains, was war das, CPU Core?
Nur dann geben wir was aus.
Excellent, das sieht auch schon deutlich besser aus.
So, und dann, wenn es nicht Distance enthält, oder wie?
Okay, das ist jetzt zwar nicht schön, aber es funktioniert.
Distance, not Distance.
So, und jetzt sollten wir die richtigen Sachen rauskriegen.
Nämlich nur CPU Core 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Sehr gut.
Tibelius, das ist sinnloses Twitch-Gesperr.
Da gibt es nichts zu verstehen, das ist einfach nur bescheuert.
Ja, das funktioniert doch eigentlich ganz gut.
So, was wir machen können ist, wir wollen ja nicht 6 CPU-Werte im Overlay anzeigen,
sondern nur einen Mittelwert.
Da können wir uns erstmal hier irgendwie Values, eine Liste machen mit Floats.
Also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass das Floats sind.
Ohne sind Nullable Floats, jetzt wird es aber hier, jetzt wird es aber advanced, Alter.
So, Values, gut, die Sensorwerte speichern wir mal in unserer Liste.
Values, Add, Sensorwerte rein.
Und am Ende geben wir das Ganze dann einfach mal aus.
Und zwar nicht hier, sondern am Ende von der Schleife.
Nullable Floats, jawoll, Danny, das ist so eine Geschichte.
Klingt erstmal abstrus, ja.
Aber es ergibt sogar in dem Fall Sinn.
Null ist halt Referenz Null gemeint und nicht Null, weil Excellent BigBrain.
Ich weiß, ich kann es hier auch im Wehr machen, aber da wird es unsinnig lang.
So, das ist eh nicht schön, da gibt es bestimmt eine schönere Variante.
So, und jetzt sagen wir mal hier Values, Min, ne, was zum Teufel ist Durchschnitt?
Aggregate, Summen, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Hier, Average, Average, wie haben wir das ausgesprochen?
So.
Was hast du dir noch mal genau von GitHub gezogen?
Libre Hardware Monitor habe ich mir runtergeladen hier, guck.
Libre Hardware Monitor und da drin ist im.NET Standard 2.0 Ordner eine Library, die du verwenden kannst dafür.
So, mal gucken, was meine Durchschnitts-CPU-Temperatur ist.
71 Grad.
Ich hoffe mal, das ist in Celsius.
Wenn nicht, ist, äh, doof.
Ähm, probieren wir das doch mal aus.
Mal, äh, ähm, Task, Run, ne, Task, Run, wir führen das einfach mal in den neuen Task in der Schleife aus.
Task, Run, wir machen das einfach mal in der Schleife und, äh, führen das, führen das alle zwei Sekunden oder so mal aus.
Wir sind ja aktuell eher dabei, rauszukriegen, wie es überhaupt funktioniert.
Und jetzt machen wir was, wo alle wieder sagen, OMG, das kann man doch nicht machen, das geht doch nicht.
Threats, Leap für eine Sekunde.
Bam, fertig. Jetzt schauen wir mal, ob das klappt.
Ja.
So, jetzt müssen wir natürlich auch gucken, ob der Kram auch wirklich funktioniert.
Ähm, der ja, 71 Grad, der rendert ja auch Video im Hintergrund für den Stream.
Das ist, glaube ich, ganz in Ordnung.
Habe ich noch Prime 95 drauf? Prime 95? Ah, ne.
Diese Windows-Suche jebaitet mich immer. Ich denke, ich habe was installiert, obwohl ich nichts installiert habe.
Okay, laden wir uns mal das beste Programm zum CPU-Temperatur-Check-In runter.
Äh, da, Prime 95.
Paar Heise, wir können doch Paar Heise runterladen.
Ich hoffe allerdings nicht, dass der Stream dann laggt.
Dann stellen wir das einfach mal auf nicht alle Cores ein.
Oh, die sind schon bei Version 29.8b6. Exzellent.
Prime 95.
Das anzippe ich mal hier rein.
Wobei...
Ne, das anzippe ich nicht hier rein. Das anzippe ich hier irgendwo rein.
Ah, da, da anzippe ich das rein. Da, hier, da.
Ah, einfach mal zum Ausprobieren, weil danach lösche ich es wieder.
So, probieren wir das Ganze mal aus. Es läuft.
Wir machen mal kurz den Start raus, weil der Start sieht ein bisschen doof aus, wenn das hier jetzt mal kommt.
Okay.
Da haben wir die CPU-Temperatur.
Und jetzt starten wir mal Prime 95 und schauen, ob die CPU-Temperatur nennenswert hochgeht.
Wohlgemerkt, die CPU-Temperatur hier ist folgendermaßen.
Das ist der Durchschnitt.
Der Durchschnitt über alle 6 CPU-Kerne.
Just stress testing.
Äh, wir machen mal...
Wir machen halt 5. Ich habe 6 CPU-Kerne und wir machen mal 5 Threads auf.
Und wir testen...
Highest heat, okay.
Wow.
Es funktioniert. Es wird warm.
Mein Lüfter dreht hoch.
Mein Lüfter geht an.
Ruckelt das Stream oder geht noch alles?
Der steigt nicht schnell. Der bleibt ziemlich konstant auf so 84.
Der Lüfter dreht ja auch nur so schnell, wie er drehen muss. Das ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Was hast du für einen Lüfter? Einen Noctua, den fetten Noctua-Lüfter.
Den fettesten Noctua-Lüfter.
Und ich würde sagen, der läuft jetzt so auf... Ah, da können wir doch gerade mal nachgucken.
Mal gucken, ob man das starten kann parallel.
Da können wir nämlich gerade mal nachgucken, was man CPU-Lüfter so macht.
Mal gucken, ob man das parallel starten kann.
Kann man das parallel starten?
Anscheinend, anscheinend.
Okay, das wird halt zwischenzeitlich ziemlich warm.
Lüfter?
Wo ist denn der Lüfter? Seht ihr den Lüfter?
Ah, Fan.
Ja gut, ich weiß nicht, was da von der CPU-Fan ist.
NHD15, ja, ja, richtig.
Ist das hier der CPU-Lüfter oder das hier?
Ich weiß nicht.
Nee, das ist nicht warm. Ich meine, das Ding ist mehr oder weniger voll ausgelastet.
Und der Lüfter läuft noch nicht mal auf Anschlag.
Das ist vollkommen okay. Der ist 10 Grad kälter als er...
Ich glaube, der darf sogar 105 werden, ne?
Ich glaube, theoretisch darf er sogar 105 werden, bevor er abschaltet oder bevor er runter regelt.
Der ist 10 Grad oder sogar 12, 10, 12, 13 Grad unter Max.
Unter quasi nahezu voller Auslastung.
Da kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Ordentlich.
Komm mal, er geht sogar auch hier nur hoch auf 4, 4, 5.
Da müsste er aber eigentlich mindestens auf 4, 7 gehen. Ach, was auch immer. Who cares?
Sehr gut, also zumindest, man sieht, es funktioniert.
Wenn ich den Kram wieder ausmache, stopp, okay.
Dann geht es auch wieder runter.
Also, das, was wir testen wollten, hat funktioniert.
Das Auslesen der CPU-Temperatur klappt.
Ah, AVX, deswegen wird der Shit so warm.
Du hast vollkommen recht, Tbilius, das habe ich ganz vergessen.
Ja, natürlich, das müssen wir noch ausmachen.
Kann man das überhaupt ausmachen? Stimmt, wie war das nochmal?
Oh, jaja, das weiß ich noch, das ist so eine Geschichte mit Prime 95, was mich immer durcheinander bringt.
Wo ging das nochmal mit dem...
Er ist auch der einzige 5-Hat-Moment deines Lebens. Ach, was.
Das ist bestimmt immer 5-Hat.
Du bist mittlerweile schon einfach so lange und so oft 5-Hat, dass dir gar nicht mehr auffällt, dass du 5-Hat bist.
Also, Vorstufe zu 6-Hat.
Das ist so ein unglaublich dämliches Twitch-Chat-Geschwafel, aber der Chat versteht, was ich meine.
Äh, hier, Torture-Tests.
Kann ich das nicht disablen?
Und das ist nicht, okay.
Stimmt, du hast recht, AVX Offset, das ist das Richtige, genau.
Okay.
Ah, guck mal hier.
Da bleibt das Ganze auch schon ein bisschen kühler.
So, und wie viel taktet er jetzt? Schauen wir mal.
Okay. Juckt ihn nicht. Juckt ihn überhaupt nicht.
Aber das ist der, du hast vollkommen recht, das ist der AVX Offset.
Ich kenne das, ich hatte genau das gleiche Problem am Anfang beim Testen, dass ich nie auf den Maximal-Takt gekommen bin.
Ähm, weil das mit AVX Offset ist.
Ehrlich gesagt, Leute, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe jetzt auch keinen Bock, das großartig weiter zu debuggen, weil drauf geschissen.
Das Programm funktioniert, das ist das, worauf es ankommt.
Sehr gut, so, den Kram stoppen. Jawoll, Prime, nein.
Prime 95 ausmachen.
So, können wir weiter machen. Okay, das klappt schon mal ganz gut.
Also sprich, wir können CPU Temperatur auslesen.
Ähm, natürlich ist es ein bisschen doof, die CPU Temperatur hier im Main-Window auszulesen, aber erst einmal vollkommen, vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ähm, jetzt machen wir das Overlay.
Ach so, GPU Temperatur brauchen wir ja auch noch.
Computer, dann machen wir hier GPU, GPU Enabled, True.
Ja, gut, dann funktioniert mein Filter hier aber nicht richtig.
Wie heißt denn der Sensor, Sensor Name, wie heißt denn der Sensor für GPU Core, GPU Core, okay.
Na gut.
Okay, dann machen wir einfach noch ein anderes If unten drunter, wenn es GPU Core ist.
Also, If.
Mal oben drüber, ist auch egal.
If Sensor Name, äh, wobei, wenn das Sensor Name, das Ding heißt ja immer, heißt GPU Core, dann GPU Core setzen.
Da machen wir jetzt einen Label Overlay und gut ist.
Ah, richtig Big Brain Idee, aber funktioniert nicht.
Vorti, das ist eine richtig gute Idee.
Das hier wäre eine richtig gute Idee, aber das funktioniert nicht, weil ich will ja nicht den Durchschnittswert von CPU und GPU Temperatur haben.
Ich muss den Unterschied, also die Idee finde ich richtig gut, aber das funktioniert in dem Fall nicht.
Ich will nämlich nur den Durchschnitt der CPU Temperatur und die GPU Temperatur will ich einzeln haben.
Aber die Idee ist, äh, exzellent.
So, jetzt brauchen wir ein paar Felder in unserem Fenster, wo man, oh, WPF Leute, ich hab Jahre kein WPF mehr gemacht.
Äh, Toolbox.
Label, hä?
Label.
Ich hab jahrelang kein WPF mehr gemacht, ich hab da keinen Plan mehr von, wie das funktioniert.
Wie setzt man hier überhaupt, äh,
Schriftgröße?
20 Pixels.
Zu klein.
26 Pixels, perfekt.
Label.
Noch ein Label.
GPU, CPU.
Benutz doch WinUI.
Hehehe, tolle Idee.
Tbilius, man merkt das, ja, der Chat-IQ steigt ins Unermessliche langsam, ich merk's, ich merk's richtig, richtig.
Big, wahnsinnig big brain.
Okay, probieren wir das mal aus.
Ich hab so lang kein WPF mehr verwendet, dass ich echt gar nicht mehr weiß, wie das überhaupt funktioniert.
Label.
Wie greife ich bei WPF überhaupt noch mal auf die Elemente zu?
Ich weiß es legit nicht.
Name?
Ich hab echt keine Ahnung.
Ah, man muss den Ding einen Namen geben.
Stimmt, stimmt, ich erinnere mich.
Name, also.
CPU.
GPU.
Das funktioniert ja so nicht, da krieg ich Threat Exceptions, das ist mir auch klar.
Label.
Wie setzt man nur Text, Content, Content geht das, Content so.
So, das heißt, ich muss jetzt irgendwie erst mal sagen, Invoke.
Och, meine Güte, WPF, wie geht denn das, Invoke in WPF.
Ja, keine Ahnung, muss ich nachgucken.
Ah, Dispatcher Invoke war es, genau.
Dispatcher Invoke, das wäre ja sonst zu einfach, wenn man das einfach so schreiben könnte, wie man das gewohnt ist.
Also Leute, ihr seht, es ist wichtig, wo wir wieder beim eigentlichen Punkt sind, was ich immer sage, es ist wichtig, dass man genug weiß, dass man das googlen kann.
Man muss das überhaupt nicht aus dem Kopf wissen.
Ist das etwa Max FPS?
Ich weiß nicht, was du meinst.
So, also, dann haben wir hier CPU, Content ist gleich, nee nee nee, GPU, GPU, Content ist gleich, Sensor Value, kann man das so direkt setzen?
Geht das? Probieren wir mal aus, ob das geht.
Hey!
Okay, das scheint zu funktionieren.
Ich bin überrascht.
Ich bin überrascht, dass das doch so gut funktioniert.
Okay, dann machen wir hier unten das gleiche nochmal, ich gebe zu, das ist hyper, hyper eklig, was wir hier machen, aber für so kleine Testzwecke sollte es ausreichen.
Warum aber CPU?
CPU.
Warum geht mein CPU Wert nicht?
Warum geht der GPU Wert und der CPU Wert geht nicht?
Weil...
Es sind Float, ist...
Keine CPU verbaut.
Ah, ich bin ja auch ein Kacknoob.
Die sind ja zwei Elemente in der Schleife drin.
Komm, oder hast du es nicht funktioniert?
Klar funktioniert das nicht.
Weil der überschreibt das mit der Grafikkarte hier oben.
ZAPCOM? Nee, habe ich nicht mal probiert, nachdem das Ding so viel Disk Space gefressen hat, werde ich das auch anders machen.
Ich installiere mal Virtual Box und probiere das so direkt aus, dann läuft es nämlich auch.
Das kann so gar nicht funktionieren, weil ich ja das jetzt überschreibe.
Also ich muss im Endeffekt, ich darf das nur einmal machen.
Und zwar mal ganz einfach.
Wir machen das nämlich einfach außerhalb der Schleife.
So, und dann funktioniert es. Passt auf.
Poggers, geht. CPU Temperatur, GPU Temperatur.
Vielleicht sollten wir das noch davor schreiben.
Wir schreiben das noch davor.
CPU.
Warum steht da jetzt Label doppelt drin?
Der WPF Designer ist so abartig eklig, Alter.
Ich weiß, die WPF Pros machen das mit irgendeinem Stackpanel oder sonst was.
Ich konnte das auch mal ganz gut, diesen XML Dialekt hier, aber ich habe so lange nichts mal richtig in WPF gemacht.
Ich bin ein kompletter Kacknoob jetzt. Hab das alles vergessen.
So, und das ist GPU.
So, gucken wir mal, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Ja, exzellent.
Ich bin begeistert. So, vielleicht sollten wir die Farben noch anpassen.
Was ist eine gute Farbe für CPU und was ist eine gute Farbe für GPU, Leute?
Wir runden das nochmal.
Äh, nicht to string. Was war man da?
Wir können das zu einem Incast, aber das ist nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache. Wir müssen das hier machen.
Kann man das nicht hier einfach zu einem Incast und dann schneidet das Ganze ab und gut ist?
Ah, so ist das gut.
Ja, so gefällt mir das Ganze.
Leute, ich würde so gerne WinUI 3 verwenden, ja.
Aber ich war richtig enttäuscht, als wir das vor ein paar Tagen im Stream angeguckt haben,
dass man immer noch UWP Packaging Crap braucht, um das zum Laufen zu kriegen.
Das macht es komplett useless für mich.
Aber ich habe gesehen, in ihrer Roadmap stehen Unpackaged Anwendungen drinnen.
Das heißt, das kommt hoffentlich noch.
Vorti, das gefällt mir, das ist eine gute Idee.
Das schreibe ich immer auf, das bauen wir noch ein.
Farbe, das bauen wir noch ein, aber ich will standardmäßig nur, dass es nicht ganz so ekelig,
nicht so schwarz-weiß aussieht.
Also den Hintergrund machen wir eh gleich transparent, ne?
Sollen wir hier die Farbe einstellen?
Wie stellt man überhaupt Farbe ein?
Brush?
Oh.
Also nehmen wir mal für die CPU Temperatur, nehmen wir mal rot.
Nein, nein, nicht Hintergrund.
Text.
Appearance.
Leute, ich bin legit zu blöd, in WPF die Farbe einzustellen.
Ah, Brush Foreground.
Excellent.
CPU war mal rot, volle Pole rot und fett.
Ich weiß schon, warum ich das niemals über den Editor gemacht habe früher.
Genau.
So und GPU machen wir hier.
Hallo?
Ne, komm.
So hier, das ist doch okay.
So und jetzt müssen wir den Hintergrund noch transparent machen.
So, das funktioniert schon mal.
Okay, meine CPU, meine GPU Temperatur update sich nicht, aber meinetwegen.
So und das nächste muss ich mir abgucken.
Transp, allow transparency war das, genau.
True.
Das musste man setzen.
Wow.
Das muss ich abgucken.
Das kriege ich nicht mal gebacken.
Das muss ich abgucken aus meiner Meme Tool.
Da ist es.
Das haben wir nämlich hier schon mal gemacht alles.
Main Windows, ja da ist es.
Wie ist eigentlich deine Meinung zu den Corona Maßnahmen?
Ich finde es zum größten Teil sinnvoll.
Allerdings, was ich ein bisschen vermisse ist, dass man die Maßnahmen für Normalsterbliche erklärt und begründet, warum man was macht.
Das vermisse ich bei der ganzen Sache.
Und das XAML muss man noch aufmachen.
Das ist irgendwie ein Mario Outro, genau, beste.
Also was müssen wir hier stellen?
Window Style None, Background Transparent und Allow Transparency.
Das muss man einstellen.
Genau, ich erinnere mich.
Jetzt wo ich wieder sehe.
Gut, dass wir das alle schon mal gemacht haben irgendwann.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Ist das nicht poggers?
Massive.
Excellent.
Hier.
Es funktioniert noch nicht ganz. Ich weiß auch, warum es noch nicht ganz funktioniert, weil es noch nicht topmost ist das Window.
Aber das ist doch schon mal nice, oder?
Overlay.
Massive Overlay.
Vielleicht sollten wir noch eine Sache machen und zwar.
Vielleicht sollten wir noch hinten dran schreiben, dass das ein Template String ist.
Und zwar.
Ein Template String mit, dass man auch eine Einheit hinten dran hat.
Sonst ist das ein bisschen blöd.
Das können wir einfach so.
Machen das da genauso.
Ich meine Einheiten overrated, gebated.
Wie ist es eigentlich? Leerzeichen zwischen Zahl und Einheit oder nicht?
Oh, da bin Dollar zu viel.
Hast du dir mal Aussagen wegen Kritik an der Maßnahme angehört, zum Beispiel ausbleibender Übersterblichkeit?
Ja, ich gucke mir da regelmäßig Videos zu an.
Eine weitere Sache, die ich auch blöd finde, ist, dass aktuell so viel mit den Worten sowas wie Verschwörungstheoretiker oder Aluhutleute und so um sich geworfen wird.
Ich finde, es hat jede Seite verdient, mal zumindest, dass man sich anhört, was sie zu sagen haben.
Weil wenn eine Sache Hass zwischen unterschiedlichen Gruppierungen erzeugt, ist es, wenn man die eine Seite quasi nur belächelt und sie überhaupt nicht ernst nimmt und die auch überhaupt nicht zuhört.
Ich glaube, es haben alle Seiten verdient, dass man ihnen zumindest mal zuhört, was sie zu sagen haben.
Und ob man das dann für irgendwas verwendet, ist wieder was anderes.
Aber ich bin der Ansicht, es haben alle Seiten, egal wie verrückt sie sind, oftmals Teile zumindest, die gar nicht so blöde sind.
Und aktuell werden viele Sachen einfach komplett, jegliche Diskussion abgewürgt dadurch, indem man sagt, Aluhutverschwörungstheorie ist auch nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache.
Ich finde es überhaupt nicht verkehrt, wenn man stinknormal über Sachen diskutiert. Man muss es ja nicht machen.
So, wo habe ich jetzt einen Dollar zu viel davor?
Ja, das sieht doch jetzt eigentlich schon mal ganz gut aus, oder?
Wir starten das mal ohne Debugger.
Das ist doch schon mal was.
So, machen wir das Fenster noch weg. Machen wir das Konsolenfenster weg.
Das ist doch schon mal schick.
So, und jetzt müssen wir natürlich noch einstellen, dass das Fenster oben bleibt.
Wenn das Fenster nicht oben bleibt, ist ziemlich, ziemlich bescheuert.
Und was auch ein Problem ist, ich zeige es euch mal, was auch ein Problem ist, ich glaube, wir können nicht, wir können nicht durchklicken. Seht ihr?
Wir können nicht durchklicken. Das sind aber zwei Sachen, die haben wir glücklicherweise schon gemacht.
Das heißt, wir können einfach abgucken, wie das Ganze funktioniert.
Ich glaube, das erste ist, wir müssen hier Top Most oder so einstellen. Top. Top Most.
Warte, musste man hier Top Most einstellen? Top Most True, genau.
True, 0W.
So, jetzt bleibt das Fenster schon mal immer im Vordergrund, wenn man rumklickt.
Guck hier, haben wir unser schönes Overlay.
Dreh tisch, lass die Leute doch dummes Zeug labern.
Man muss ja nichts drauf geben.
So.
Das passt doch. Das ist doch nice.
Show in Taskbar Falls. Richtig, haben wir das hier auch?
Wir können quasi alles eins zu eins abgucken, das ist doch nice.
Show in Taskbar Falls.
Das lassen wir mal True, weil, wenn ich das jetzt ohne Debugger starte und verkacke, dann habe ich kein Fenster mehr, um es auszuschalten.
Das machen wir dann ganz zum Schluss, schalten wir das auf Falls.
Ja, natürlich finde ich es auch bescheuert, wenn Leute anfangen und erzählen, dass irgendwie Bill Gates hier die große Verschwörung plant oder so.
Aber ganz ehrlich, es tut mir irgendwie weh, wenn Leute Bullshit erzählen. Nee, sollen sie machen.
Ich lache mich da teilweise drüber kaputt, genauso wie ich mir gerne Videos von Flat Earth Leuten angucke und mir denke, was zum Teufel ist bei euch los?
Aber, ey, sollen sie doch.
Es ist allemal besser, als prinzipiell immer allen den Mund zu verbieten und permanent zu sagen, ah, das ist Verschwörungstheorie, das ist Aluhut, das ist hier, das ist jenes.
Sollen sie doch alle sagen, was sie wollen.
Naja, wenn sie anfangen, 5G-Masten abzufackeln, tut dir das schon weh. Das ist jetzt ja aber schon ziemlich weiter Sprung, ja.
Das ist jetzt schon ziemlich weiter Sprung von irgendjemand, ist da der Ansicht, 5G könnte was mit Corona zu tun haben, zu erfackeln, ab.
Natürlich bin ich nicht dafür, dass Leute Masten abfackeln, aber pauschal zu sagen, nur weil du jetzt quasi Kritik übst an Corona-Maßnahmen, bist du ein Aluhut-Träger oder Verschwörungstheoretiker,
das ist einfach zu schnell, man kann sich das doch anhören, ja. Und wenn die Leute wiederholen Bullshit erzählen, ja, dann geht es mir halt ins eine Ohr rein, ins andere raus.
Aber ich denke, es hat jede Seite erstmal, das Recht kann man nicht sagen, aber es sollte, man sollte es jeder Seite zugestehen, auch wenn es erstmal so aussieht, als es Schwachsinn, dass man sich zumindest mal anhört, was sie zu sagen hat.
Genauso erwarte ich aber auch, genauso erwarte ich auch, dass wenn Maßnahmen getroffen werden, dass die den Leuten ordentlich erklärt werden.
Das ist eigentlich mein größtes Problem bei der ganzen Geschichte, ich finde die Corona-Maßnahmen eigentlich vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ich habe damit überhaupt kein Problem, ich finde das sogar gut und ich bin der Meinung, in manchen Bereichen sollte man sogar noch ein bisschen mehr machen, weil es die Leute nicht dran halten.
Aber man muss es den Leuten erklären und das passiert nicht. Es wird gesagt, wir machen das, wir machen jenes, jetzt machen wir es wieder anders, wir machen es in Hessen dort anders, wir machen es in Bayern dort anders, aber das ist ja bei uns normal.
Dann gibt es hier ein paar Ausnahmen und hier, ohne dass eine ordentliche Kommunikation erfolgt, warum Maßnahmen getroffen werden, was man sich alternativ überlegt hat und warum es genau diese Maßnahme sein muss.
So, das, das müsste, das müsste sein und das gibt es nicht.
Weil ansonsten ist es so, ist es ungefähr so, wie wenn euer Chef sagt, ab heute verdonnern wir dich zu jeden Tag Rechenzentrumsrundgang zu machen.
Da werdet ihr auch sagen, hä, warum, habe ich irgendwas angestellt oder so, was ist los?
Wenn ihr dir das jetzt allerdings erklärt, ja, also wenn dein Chef einfach nur sagt, alter jetzt jeden Tag RZ-Rundgang, dann denkst du, will der mich ärgern, was ist hier los, warum, warum hat er das entschieden, dann gibt es doch überhaupt keinen Sinn, ja.
Wenn er dir aber erklärt, warum das jetzt sinnvoll ist, dass du das machst und sei es nur, dass der Kollege das gerade macht, nicht da ist und man selbst die meiste Erfahrung noch in dem Bereich hat und was auch immer.
Wenn er dir das halbwegs sinnvoll erklärt, dann kannst du auch dahinter stehen und sagen, ja, ok, leuchtet ein, verstehe ich.
Wenn es dir einfach nur einer sagt, du musst das jetzt machen ohne Erklärung, dann hat das immer so ein bisschen bitteren Beigeschmack.
Du kannst nur die Leute wirklich von was überzeugen, wenn du es ihnen erklärst und wenn sie es nachvollziehen können.
Wenn sie es nachvollziehen können und wenn einer dann trotzdem noch sagt, finde ich bescheuert, kann er das machen, aber zumindest ist es dann nicht grundlos von oben entschieden.
Man hat zumindest die Chance nachzuvollziehen.
Und das ist das, was ich ein bisschen vermisse an der ganzen Sache.
So, wo sind wir hier stehen geblieben?
Wir wollten, wir wollten, wir wollten machen, dass man durch Fenster klicken kann. Das ist nämlich wichtig, weil ansonsten, guckt hier, ansonsten kann ich nichts anklicken, weil das Fenster davor ist.
Seht ihr das?
Oder doch?
Ich kann doch durchklicken?
Moment.
Kann ich ja doch durchklicken.
Ah, nee, nee, nee.
Ich kann nur durchklicken, wo es transparent ist und nicht durchklicken, wo die Zahlen sind.
Okay, das will ich nicht haben. Ich will komplett durchklickbares Fenster haben, weil ansonsten hast du den Overlay und du kannst manche Sachen drunter nicht anklicken.
Das ist crap. Das muss weg.
Ja, kann man dem eigentlich sagen, dass er Fullscreen machen soll?
Gibt es sogar was wie Full, Fullscreen?
Full?
Wie sagt man dem denn?
Wie macht man WPF?
Window?
Window State, hä?
Hier, maximist.
Ah, schon viel besser. Dann ist es nämlich immer oben links in der Ecke.
Sehr gut.
Dann mach alles transparent.
Wenn ich alles transparent mache, sieht man doch den Text nicht mehr.
Was bringt mir transparenter Text?
Wenn der Background transparent ist, kann man durch das Window klicken.
Ja, kann man.
Das hab ich auch gerade gemerkt, war mir so nicht klar, weil ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern kann, wie ich das hiermit gemacht hab mit den Bildchen.
Da kann man nämlich komplett durchklicken.
Aber dort, wo Text ist, geht das Ganze nicht. Deswegen müssen wir das jetzt noch einstellen.
Aber das Gute ist, wir können das alles abgucken, weil wir haben das alles schonmal gemacht.
System Tray, Captain Seekai, das ist eine gute Idee.
Ich hab noch nie System Tray in WPF gemacht.
Wie spricht man Malware aus? Malware oder Mal?
Malware? Ich sag Malware.
Also das erste. Ich weiß aber nicht, ob das jetzt so hundertprozentig korrekt ist.
Ich sag Malware.
Okay, dann gucken wir uns jetzt mal ab, wie wir das gemacht haben.
In der anderen Anwendung. Und ich weiß, das war ein bisschen big brainiger, wie das ging.
Das hat nicht so einfach funktioniert mit durchklicken.
Also gucken wir uns mal an, wie das Memboard das Ganze macht.
Weil ihr guckt, seht ihr, da kann ich komplett durchklicken.
Durch jedes Bild. Das heißt, das brauch ich im Endeffekt da auch wieder.
Also wie haben wir das denn gemacht?
Also mit Audio Player hat das nichts zu tun.
Mit Position hat das auch relativ wenig zu tun.
Set Position hat das auch nichts zu tun.
Enable Resize. Das hat auch damit nichts zu tun.
Ah, hier, guckt mal.
On Initialized.
Hardware. Set Window X transparent. Das ist es. Das brauchen wir.
Das brauchen wir.
Ich erinnere mich, den Shit brauchen wir.
Und zwar in, was? In On Initialized.
Okay, da war das doch mal.
Windows Logik.
Good.
Override.
Ach, Quatsch. Wir sind eins zu hoch.
Override. On Source Initialized.
Da wäre ich im Leben nicht drauf gekommen.
So.
Window Interop Helper. Wo kommt denn das her?
Okay, das ist da eigentlich. Ich dachte, das ist was von mir. Ist es aber gar nicht.
Native Set Window X transparent.
Das ist irgendwas, was ich selbst gebastelt habe. Das muss ich gerade nochmal aufmachen.
Native CSS. Da ist es.
Extended Window Styles.
Meine Güte, was habe ich denn da?
Was habe ich denn da zusammengebastelt, Alter?
Wir kopieren das einfach mal.
Easy.
Wir kopieren das einfach.
So.
Das wird einfach jetzt kopiert. Gut ist.
Warum soll ich den Kram nochmal neu machen?
Add New File.
Class.
Native. Oh, das sollte man vielleicht mal groß schreiben.
Native.
Yes.
Sehr gut.
Was hat er jetzt für Schmerzen? DLL Import gibt es nicht. Ja, das dachte ich mir, dass es das nicht gibt.
Okay.
War es das jetzt? Reicht das jetzt schon? Jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Das war es. Easy.
Easy.
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass das so ein einfaches Ding ist. Easy.
Kommt mal hier.
Ich kann jetzt komplett.
Komplett durchklicken.
Und es stört überhaupt nicht mehr.
Das ist ja richtig nice.
Kriege ich mal ein Poggers Overlay hier.
Massive. Wahnsinn, es funktioniert richtig gut.
Hast du mal Rider ausprobiert? Ja, Rider finde ich mittlerweile fast angenehmer als Virtual Studio.
Kann kein Xaml oder Saml, wie auch immer man das ausspricht.
Wusste ich nicht.
Allerdings fällt mir auch Cross-Platform nichts ein, wo man das bräuchte.
Doch, Avalon gibt es als Projekt, die auch Saml verwenden, aber ansonsten.
Und warum funktioniert das?
Weil hier an der Stelle, das ist eine Native Windows Funktion.
Und zwar das hier.
SetWindowAlong, das ist eine Windows API Funktion.
Und der übergibt einen Handle zum Fenster.
Und einen Style.
Und wir übergeben ihm den Style, dass er transparent sein sollte.
Dann, was auch immer, no activate ist.
Ah, ich glaube, dass er keinen Fokus bekommt.
Wir sagen Windows Settings, über die Windows API für dieses Fenster sagen wir, es soll transparent sein.
Es soll keinen Fokus bekommen können.
Ähm...
Was ist Extended Style?
Ach, hier oben.
Und Extended Style ist der bisherige Windows Style.
Plus, dass es transparent ist.
Und plus, dass es keinen Fokus bekommen kann.
Und das setzen wir über die Windows API.
Und deswegen funktioniert das.
Warum das so ist, warum Microsoft sich gedacht hat, dass das so gemacht werden muss, das weiß ich natürlich auch nicht.
Was kann der nächste Sammel mappen?
M-A-U-I, was ist M-A-U-I? Kenne ich nicht.
Ach.
Wie will Microsoft wirklich einen Cross-Platform-U-I-Framework machen?
Also quasi das, was ich seit fünf Jahren oder so schon erzähle, das geilste wäre überhaupt, dass man endlich mal.NET überall verwenden kann ordentlich.
Auf welcher Basis ist das?
Weil Sammarine Forms suckt, finde ich.
Was mir Sammarine Forms nicht gefällt, ist, dass die UI-Steuerelemente nicht selber malen, sondern so eine komische Native-Bridge immer drin haben,
dass du quasi die kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner verwenden musst.
Aber Linux ist bestimmt nicht unterstützt, oder?
Hey, Sammarine Forms suckt, das mag ich überhaupt nicht.
Und Desktop ist auch kacke.
Ich glaube, die Linux-Unterstützung ist immer noch ziemlich beta bei der ganzen Geschichte.
Ja, nee, das ist Müll. Dann ist leider Cross-Platform-Desktop weiter irgendwelchen hässlichen Elektron-Anwendungen vorbehalten.
Aber was willst du machen, ne?
Leute, ich hab noch eine Idee.
Ich glaube, wir sollten noch ein Outline machen.
Hat irgendjemand von unseren Big-Brain-Chat-Leuten eine Idee, kann das WPF überhaupt?
Kann WPF einen Text-Outline?
Da muss ich jetzt mal nachhaken.
WPF Text-Outline. Geht das?
Klar.
Ich weiß aber nicht, wie. Das ist schön.
Ach guck mal, da.
Muss ich das selber malen, oder?
Not so easy to do, apparently.
Warum gibt's das nicht?
Alter, das ist so fail.
First create a custom... Soll ich jetzt wirklich ein Custom Class für Outline Text machen?
Da gibt's doch bestimmt schon was. Da gibt's doch bestimmt schon was Fertiges.
Da gibt's doch bestimmt schon was Fertiges.
Was ist mit der Seite los?
SQLs, aber.
Ich mein, ich kann das einfach Stack Overflow copy-paste, ne?
Ich glaube, ich copy-paste, dass einfach Stack Overflow gut ist.
Easy.
Ich hab noch nie ein Custom-WPF-Control gemacht.
WPF Text-Outline. Ach guck mal, es gibt sogar einen.
Local Text Path.
Okay, das ist anscheinend echt komplizierter als man sich das vorstellt.
Ah, guck mal, es gibt sogar einen Microsoft.
Was?
Was? Ich verstehe überhaupt nicht, was die hier machen.
Formatted Text Object.
Okay. Formatted Text Object.
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung, was hier passiert.
Ich hab legit keinen Plastenschimmer, was hier passiert.
Okay, nice.
Gibt es denn hier sowas wie Formatted Text?
Ne.
Okay.
Keine Ahnung. Ich will aber ein Outline haben. Ohne Outline ist das ziemlich doof.
Bekommt man irgendwie deine uBlock-Config, das ist Default, einfach alles aktiviert.
Sleeping Chris hat die Big Brain-Idee.
Ich hätte jetzt einfach ein zweites Label dahinter gelegt, das halt schwarz ist.
Ne, Ne, Outline muss sein. Ich kopiere mir das jetzt einfach von Stack Overflow.
Scheiß drauf, ich will das gar nicht genau verstehen.
So, hier.
Excellent.
Da, Control.
Am Start.
So.
Machen wir mal. Hups, ich hab zu wenig kopiert.
Da machen wir mal eine neue Datei.
Die wir, wie nennen wir das Ding?
Class.
Was macht diese Klasse von ihm hier?
Outlined Text Block.
Okay.
Sehr gut.
Da kommt es rein.
Äh.
Okay.
So.
So, sehr schön. Jetzt haben wir ein eigenes Custom-Element.
Äh.
Das nicht funktioniert.
Oh, ich glaube, ich hab...
Äh.
Oh.
Moment, ich hab nicht alles copy-pasted.
Muss noch mal copy-pasten.
Too low copy-paste skills.
Ich hab nur die Hälfte copy-pasted.
Sollen wir hier Stack Overflow copy-pasten?
Das ist das Wichtigste, was man können muss.
So, jetzt aber, ha?
Ja.
Sehr gut.
Jetzt haben wir's.
So, das heißt, wir können das hier jetzt verwenden.
Und zwar können wir jetzt ein, äh, ein Objekt anlegen,
das wie heißt?
Local Outlined Text Block.
Okay, probieren wir mal aus, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Ah.
Namespace.
Oh Gott, ist das kompliziert.
Ich erinnere mich an den ganzen Müll.
Nur noch dunkel.
Outlined Text Block does not exist in Namespace.
Warum nicht?
Oder doch?
Was?
Ah.
Muss ich irgendeine Resource anlegen oder so?
Eieieieiei.
Eieieieieiei.
Hier.
Stroke.
Static Resource Text Stroke.
Also manchmal ist BPF echt...
Oh, wie verwende ich das jetzt?
Wie verwende ich das jetzt?
Phil.
Kann man da nicht einfach reinschreiben?
Black oder so?
Black?
Ah.
Stroke.
Red.
Ah, haha.
Ah, das sieht doch schon besser aus.
Okay, okay, verstehe.
Verstehe.
Excellent.
Stack Overflow Copy Paste.
So funktioniert's, Leute.
So muss das sein.
Extra Bold.
Okay, wir machen das jetzt mal so, dass ich das auch ordentlich lesen kann.
Weil ich hab wahnsinnig viel Platz hier für meinen Editor.
Hier gefühlt fünf Zeilen oder so.
Okay.
Ah.
Drei.
Vier.
Oh.
Drei.
Ah.
Zwei.
26.
Bold.
Jetzt haben wir doch hier auch alles eingestellt, oder?
Fond Weight Bold, Foreground, sonst was.
Fond Size 26, Fond Weight.
Bloß, dass wir hier Standard Fond haben.
Wir haben Standard Fond.
Okay, die können wir auch mal nehmen.
Das glaube ich auch nicht.
Ach, was auch immer, Alter.
Das ist kompliziert.
So, gut.
Dann braucht das Ding einen Name.
Dann nennen wir das doch einfach mal um.
Das hier ist Name.
CPU.
Dann machen wir Name CPU weg.
Kann man das auskommentieren?
Ja.
Und dann ist das hier Name CPU.
So, dann sollte das eigentlich updaten, wenn ich starte.
Wow.
Was ist jetzt verkehrt?
Ah.
Kein Content.
Ja, und wie setze ich da Text jetzt drinne?
Wie setze ich da jetzt Text drinne?
Ich kriege echt Anfälle.
WPF, Alter.
Ach so, einfach Text setzen.
Excellent.
Sehr gut.
Ah.
Das sieht doch schon mal besser aus, oder?
Das sieht doch schon mal viel besser aus.
Sehr gut.
Ähm.
Hallo?
Oh, der Editor, please.
Editor, lass mich editieren.
Alter.
Oh.
MonkaS.
Das ist ja abartig.
Okay.
Also, dann machen wir jetzt erstmal die Farbe richtig.
Ähm.
Fill.
Red.
Nee.
Fill.
Red.
Stroke.
White.
Oder was passt denn, was passt denn da gut?
Was passt denn da gut?
Das sieht doch eigentlich ganz okay aus.
Temp.
Okay.
Ähm.
Dann kopieren wir das mal.
Machen das hier weg.
Der Editor macht mich verrückt.
Ich muss den Kram von Hand.
Okay.
Und da gibt es nicht Temp, sondern CPU.
Ah, nee.
Das ist das Falsche.
Wo ist das denn hier?
So.
What?
Was hat denn der Editor da?
Ach, hier.
Ah, Text.
Text.
CPU.
Ah, ja.
Okay.
So, funktioniert der Kram jetzt wenigstens.
Ja, ja, funktioniert.
Und sieht gleich viel besser aus, oder?
Stimmt, du hast recht, man kann das hier oben, man kann das doch hier oben irgendwie umschalten,
ne?
Genau.
So, das sieht doch schon mal deutlich besser aus.
Was ist mit euch los?
Warum rückt es das nicht richtig ein?
Alter ppega Microsoft.
Was ist mit euch los?
Keck.
der rückt nicht richtig ein vielleicht vielleicht ah das wegen das wegen das
ah ja alles klar ok was auch immer
kann man das nämlich auch so machen das so zack zack zack
ne da ist jetzt der zeichen dazwischen immer ist das ein krampf
ok cpu margin dann haben wir noch text das ist temp platzhalter gut kann man das
weg sein fix lesen sehr schön cpu temperatur haben wir das war das ganze
noch für gpu kopieren wir einfach copy paste zack unten drunter was habe ich jetzt
gemacht unten drunter weg damit das da hier zack drunter cpu text gpu und temp
kriegt name gpu alles klar dann ändern wir jetzt hier noch dass der nicht auf
content sondern auf text geht und dann sollte es eigentlich funktionieren ja
nice jetzt müssen ordentliche farben einstellen und dann funktioniert
das doch das doch nice also was für eine farbe nehmen wir denn jetzt hier von
ach guck mal jetzt kann man es hier im editor auch machen
vorher vorher ging das nicht so also vorher hatten wir zum film haben
irgendwie so ein orangenschnur irgendwie sind orange tonfeuer
nice das doch cool das doch richtig pockharts jetzt da kann man jetzt echt
nichts mal gegen sagen oder ein nicest overlay
ich muss sagen das overlay ist schöner als nvidia fraps oder oder immer sie
afterburner allerdings funktioniert es nur in also in fullscreen richtig echten
quasi exklusiv fullscreen anwendung wird das wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren
jetzt noch in sys tray was hast du so in deinem pc in 8700k 1080 ti und 230
gigabyte ram und paar ssd nice oder leute ich bin ich bin begeistert wie gut
das ist ist chill chill im eck noch am start wie weit bist du bei dir wie wie
schaut es bei dir aus
nein das wollte ich gar nicht drücken
machs lieber rechts hin links viel verdeckt ja das kann man das könnte da
könnte man eine option da könnte man eine optik könnte man eine option für
machen ich lasse jetzt erst mal links da könnte man eine option für machen dass
man das fall dass man das verschiebt und auch die größe könnte man könnte man
einstellen
heißt es ich muss sagen das gefällt mir echt gut
das das hat irgendwie was habe noch nie was mit wpf gemacht da ich wie gesagt
siehst du bei mir ist das auch schon eine ganze weile her
gibt es noch eine bessere variante für das für den auf für das outline
wie sieht das mit eins aus mit eins sieht sie krepp krepp aus oder
ne mit eins sieht so pixellig aus drumherum
so cpu temp gpu temp was wir mal gucken können wie ist es wenn man es dann
nebeneinander macht
ist auch nicht verkehrt genug platz hat man hier hinten für noch eine weitere
zahl ist auch nicht verkehrt
was meint ihr untereinander nebeneinander als 1,5 1,5
sehe ich jetzt nicht viel unterschied wir lassen es jetzt einfach mal auf zwei
das ist schon ok so cpu temperatur ist rot gpu
temperatur mama mama kommen wir mal jetzt richtig was was richtig eklig ist
m
noch viel besser so wir machen es mal ein bisschen kleiner
das stimmt schon wir machen mal font size nur machen wir machen font size
mal bis sie bis sie weiter runter wir machen font size mal auf font size
gibt's nicht jebaited mal 16 oder so 16
ja das ist glaube ich von der größe her besser als so als so wahnsinnig fett
hallo
ja wir machen wir machen das mal kleiner hier 16 16 16 ist besser 16
ok und das ganze bissl weiter hoch so so finde ich das ganz und jetzt kann man
wahrscheinlich auch den stroke auf eins machen
ja das sieht so das sieht so kacke pixellig aus dann
wobei es ist ok oder wie ist besser mit einser stroke oder mit zweier stroke
ja so sieht schon so sieht man halt die farbe nicht gut ja ein so ist besser
sieht man mehr gut exzellent fertig passt tot overlay gebastelt easy easy so
jetzt müssen natürlich auch ausprobieren ob es auch wirklich funktioniert
ach so ein tray eiken wie macht man ein tray eiken in wpf habe ich auch noch nie
gemacht ok ein tray eiken wpf tray eiken wpf application only tray eiken wpf
womit der gibt es eine eigene library what system tray eikens mit wpf scheint
er ziemlich kompliziert zu sein in tray eiken zu machen also tray eiken sind die
dinge hier unten no what the fuck was warum warum ist das so kompliziert
otto her ist es da nicht eingebaut oder was
notif ihr eiken ist not implemented in wpf ich weiß schon warum ich nichts in
wpf macht sonst
aber man kann aber man kann das windows forms notify eiken verwenden das ist ja
big brain alarm das ist ja big brain das windows forms notify eiken bin mal
erst jahre ist denn
aber das kann ich doch nicht einfach jetzt hier in klubbende kann ich einfach
windows forms in klubbende geht das
reference system windows forms ok das geht aber hiermit wahrscheinlich nicht
oder reference project reference
ja ich denke mal dass man es mit dotnet core auch machen kann aber vielleicht
braucht man das vielleicht ist es ja hier nur get package reference was
system windows forms machen wir machen wir machen wir alles
nee anscheinend nicht das geht wahrscheinlich in wpf nicht richtig in
dotnet core use dotnet core use geht das
ah microsoft windows desktop app oder was oder wie oder was
nee das geht nicht das geht nicht man kann man kann das mit dotnet core wohl
nicht machen das ist wohl wenn aus forms oder wps wpf ist anscheinend exklusiv
ok das ist natürlich ziemlich doof dann also doch das github project github wpf
tray eiken womit würde man all so eine anwendung dann besser machen als mit
wpf windows forms das ist ja gerade das problem das microsoft desktop
entwicklung seit jahren nichts gescheites auf die reihe kriegt es gibt
nichts es gibt uwp allerdings hat uwp ganz andere
probleme uwp hat zum beispiel das problem dass du dich entscheiden musst
willst du deine anwendung über die windows store verteilen oder willst du
300 euro im jahr bezahlen dass du überhaupt eine anwendung entwickeln
darfst weil du einen code signing zertifikat brauchst ist beides fehlen
so können die dotnet core können die dotnet core diese library hier
it hasn't been released super hier gibt es das nicht gibt es das hier drinnen
moment ist auch genau das gleiche ok ich glaube dass mit dem tray eiken ist zu
advanced dafür dass das das geht damit nicht
trey eiken wps dotnet core
aha
erneut die feigen kann ich nicht einbinden erzähle auch kein mist ja das
geht auch so gar nicht ja adreference
was
warum ist der krab so unglaublich kompliziert so den kakt rei eiken zu
machen ja um mal darauf zurückzukommen zebellung es gibt für windows nichts
gescheites microsoft ist was ui mäßig anbelangt haben die letzten 15 jahre
nichts gemacht die hatten mal windows forms danach hatten sie wpf wpf ist von 2006
gibt schon ewig keine updates mehr viele aktuelle sachen gehen unter wpf nicht
irgendwann haben sie angefangen mit winrt und uwp das problem mit uwp ist
dass du nicht halt entscheiden musst ob store was keiner will oder ob code
signing zertifikat das deine anwendung verteilen kann was auch scheiße ist oder
das haben wir so dass du die anwendung installieren kannst ohne dass der
anwender ohne dass der anwender auf einmal rudrechte braucht
oh guck mal da da hat einer was gefunden auf github exzellent
es sieht ja sehr vertrauenswürdiges repo aus
dann nehmen wir das doch gibt es als nur geteig
gibt es als bett natürlich gibt es wieder nicht als package das ist ja echt
lächerlicher grabe
da habe ich keinen bock drauf
seine nugget
nur da gibt es keine good package für so das heißt die alte alternative ist für
windows desktop anwendung und das sieht man ja auch überall mittlerweile die
alternative ist in den web browser es gibt so viele elektronen anwendung
beziehungsweise halt browser als anwendung verkappt also als quasi
anwendung mit einem browser fenster die ganzen grossen team origin discord das
ist alles nur noch einen browser mit quasi aber bei discord ist noch ein
bisschen mehr drumherum aber im kern ist discord ein browser der halt in dem eigenen
fenster ist und es so aussieht als beste desktop anwendung ist alles browser
steam origin sind alles browser und die an die an andere halbwegs sinnvolle
alternative ist cute und 10 plus plus
ja genau ich hatte mal vor jahren ein video zu origin gemacht
ist das echt nur ein browser ja
ja guckt ich hab sogar mal ich hab ja mal vor vor jahren ein video zu gemacht zu
origin wo ich sogar die browser tools von origin gezeigt habe
zeigt euch mal hier haben wir vor jahren in video zu origin gemacht wo man hier
sogar sieht wenn man origin startet dass man in origin guckt sogar in origin hat
man sogar die
ja in origin hat man sogar die die developer tools offen also man kann man
kann quasi die die den source code der webseite von origin sich angucken also
das ist mittlerweile das meiste ist tatsächlich nur noch web browser
also das mit dem notify icon würde ich mir mal sparen weil das ist mir jetzt
ein bisschen zu merken wenn wenn es dafür an notify nur get wpf tray icon
gibt es da gibt es das für dort an kohr
ah ist es doch
ist das ist es die dotnet kohr variante wann wurde die hochgeladen vor fünf
monaten ok repo das ist das repo doch gibt es doch eine new get package von ja
dann dann nehmen wir das doch einfach epic music ja huge dann nehmen das doch einfach
sehr gut also da machen wir das doch mal add dependencies nur get package
ja ok wie farb wie verwendet man den kram denn überhaupt
excellent ok also using hard codet wpf ok wie viel funktioniert diese diese
diese library hier examples sammel deklaration example ja mein wegen
machen wir so tb also muss man als ein extra namespace hinzufügen das ist mit
wpf extra kompliziert muss man mal muss man mal sagen das ist nicht nicht so
einfach so das ganze vor allem das ganze xml geraffel an task eiken
ach ne man kann ja nur ein top level element haben ne kann man nur ein top
level element haben ich bin mal gar nicht sicher ja kann man
ok funktioniert jetzt gibt es den tray eiken
ha guck mal leute es gibt ein tray eiken es funktioniert es gibt einen tray eiken
ich meine das macht zwar noch nichts aber es gibt ein tray eiken poggers
mach ein keck w als ja das machen wir das ist eine gute idee das ist eine gute
idee images tray haben wir haben wir denn ein eco feil irgendwo dot dot eco ja
lulliko wir machen lull wir machen den lull wir machen kein keck w ich hab
kein kein keck w.ico am start wir machen das da muss muss muss jetzt reichen muss
reichen jetzt ok kopieren wir das mal irgendwie hier rein zack
lull so da müssen wir jetzt einstellen dass es immer kopiert wird und dann
haben wir hier im hauptverzeichnis einfachen lull.ico
was
ok warum geht das jetzt nicht
warum geht das jetzt nicht lull.ico warum microsoft warum geht das nicht
weil es die datei nicht gibt aber wo sucht er denn wo sucht er die datei dann
überhaupt
man die datei ist ja ist ja offensichtlich überall da
kennon locate resource lull.ico muss das irgendwie eine resource sein wie macht
man über wie legt man hier überhaupt ressourcen an mein blown kann man einfach
der datei angeben ok ressource wie wir jetzt resources
ich weiß resources nähe wie geht das
reine güte hat kompliziert er
käme ich will mal gucken was beim rechtsklick passiert maus right button ich
will kein double click fallback tooltip brauchen wir auch nicht ich will einfach
einen rechtsklick right click tray right mouse down new event händler ok ist der
jetzt irgendwo mein event händler hier drin dann sagen wir nämlich einfach mal
application exit oder so wie geht das quitt wie macht man wie macht man
überhaupt hardcoded eine wpf anwendung aus mainfenster schließen einfach main
fenster zumachen
ja ok das funktioniert schon mal da bin ich zufrieden wir können immer noch ein
menü machen wo quitt drinne steht oder so aber wenigstens kann ich da ist es
übrigens nichts kann ich zumachen so eiken eiken wie kriege ich dann ein
popel ich ist eiken rein einfach nur ein eiken sonst nix
ja eiken eiken also einfach so lull lull.ico
fail to create life from text lull.ico was from text ich will dann ein feil
angeben ok anscheinend zu advanced eiken source lull.ico wo ist das
problem was hat er für schmerzen ok wie geht das zeigt man ja text helfe für
für das
github
resource können über properties hinzugefügt ja ich dachte das geht
ach ach genau stimmt so war das ja
und da kann man da jetzt ein eiken hinterlegen in den ressources
ja
näh ich habe legit keinen plan wie das scheiß funktioniert
adress aus image eiken new eiken lull.ico
nein ich will das nicht malen
ha jebaited jebaited haben wir ihn jetzt
ja mit jebaited jetzt geht aus
ne oje wir haben es kaputt gemacht leute hättest du mal mit cobalt gemacht ja
ok delete yes
ha ich bin da echt zu dumm für
ist das falsche gelöscht möglich ok das kann auch nicht so kompliziert sein
properties resources jawoll ad existing file aha lull jetzt
ok eco weg machen einfach nur lull ja meine fresse warum ist das denn so
kompliziert was soll ich denn noch alles machen vor allem ist das wahnsinnig
unintuitiv leute habt ihr ein plan was ich machen soll da ist es hier lull
rename lull.ico
mehr cobalt wir gucken uns das jetzt hier an eco images tray eikens logo
ah guck mal der macht einen slash am anfang das ist bestimmt big brain das
das geht bestimmt einfach nur nicht ok wir machen wir machen das jetzt mal
ich habe eine idee wir machen jetzt und was eiken source wir machen jetzt
punkt slash lull equal ok
ok
tray eikens new ad folder tray eikens lull eco nein rename logo
ok resources gut weg damit brauchen wir nicht
was jetzt zu komplex würde ich ja es ist anscheinend eine wahnsinnige geschichte dort was
rein zu bekommen an eiken source huge complex würde ich sagen ich meine der witz ist ja
dass der kram ja eigentlich da ist na ja trei eikens logo.ico da ist es
es ist komplett ppega was das so kompliziert ist der kram du hast es mit
windows forms tray eiken hinbekommen das natürlich noch besser aber warum hat
irgendjemand eine klorreiche idee warum das nicht funktioniert ok schauen wir uns mal
schauen wir uns mal das example bei dem an samples sind overrated samples brauchen wir
nicht samples samples brauchen wir nicht ok ich habe noch nicht wir lassen es da weg
kann man vielleicht das tray eiken wir setzen das wir setzen das tray eiken über
wir setzen das über den best viel besser was
man muss um das gleiche verzeichnis aufzurufenden slash am anfang machen was microsoft warum
ist das vor monac es monac es war warum ist die referenz zum gleichen ordnen slash fixi
hart dankeschön excellent subscription zwei monate ok da können wir das jetzt nämlich
auch wieder umbenennen nämlich pass auf jetzt geht es nicht doch ok wow task was cancel
ja ich weiß ich habe die applikation beendet holt man nicht rum windows ich hatte auch schon
ewig ewig kein wpf mehr gemacht so wunderbar das funktioniert also wir haben wir haben
es geschafft wir haben einen eiken poggers so das heißt das können wir wieder löschen
die lied excellent wir sind jetzt ganz hartkorn wir sagen einfach application exit wie ging
das noch mal current exit nee close shut down shut down das ist die hardcore variante das
ist die hardcore variante wenn man keinen bock hat dass die anwendung irgendwelche komischen
wenn die einfach gekillt werden soll einfach in your face komplett anwendung weg so beste
ok jetzt haben wir den tray eiken und das freut mich jetzt haben wir den tray eiken wir
können die anwendung beenden huge oder ok das backt ein bisschen um rename noch bitte
deinen händler wieso also ich finde mein notification eiken tray right mouse down ist
richtig gut gefällt mir wie gut das funktioniert wie massif das wie grandios das funktioniert
wie konnte man es in einer taskbar noch mal sagen welche icons eingeblendet werden sollen
turn system icons on off so irgendwie nee ja und irgendwo müsste mein nee ja und da
ist es doch lull und jetzt ist lull aus ja so ist doch schön lull und jetzt ist lull wieder
aus sehr gut ex exquisite was ein akt als das eigentliche hat länger gebraucht für
die funktionalität an sich ok nice nice voll intuitiv zu bedienen einfach ein rechtsklick
drauf machen und close weil ansonsten müsste ich jetzt hier noch irgendwie menü anlegen
oder geschweige denn das machen wir nicht das machen wir echt nicht wir legen kein
menü an das das muss reichen das muss reichen tray eiken rechtsklick kaputt ja aber es
ist aber es ist doch es ist doch wirklich eine leiste geschichte das gefällt mir so
wir müssen jetzt natürlich noch gucken ob es funktioniert wir müssen jetzt natürlich
noch checken ob es geht also machen wir mal hier aus release bild ok rebuild bin release
starten da ist es ah das muss ich noch ausschalten mit dem minimieren das glaube ich scheut
scheuen taskbar war die geschichte weil mein overlay mein overlay wird auch nicht minimiert
von diesem shortcut das müssen wir noch ausschalten show in taskbar müssen wir noch ausmachen
schau in taskbar falls dem rebuild so also ich bin falsch bin release
so warum wird es jetzt nicht angezeigt wir haben es doch gerade wir haben es doch gerade
ok wir haben wir haben tempe keck jetzt doppelt alles klar andere tempe keck exe wunderbar
gpu ist pink ne das habe ich schon vor einer weile eingestellt guckt leute jetzt bleibt
es auch oben bei minimieren excellent so ok wir machen mal eine runde modern warfare auf
ich brauche jetzt irgendwas was funktioniert
ich dachte jetzt schon wieder 50 gigabyte mit welcher api liest du die temps aus mit
einer die mail ist nicht liegt das hat man doch jeder das haben wir doch jedes mal das
ist die donation mail und die mailie offiziell sogar auf twitch stehen
ich weiß der chat mag das wenn was geleakt wird
so schauen wir mal ob das jetzt funktioniert es müsste ja sowohl gpu als auch cpu temperatur
hochgehen wenn ich den kram anmache
interne ip liegt monka es
so wenn es jetzt im fullscreen startet dann sollte es nicht funktionieren weil fullscreen
brauchst du die direct x und opengl hooks und das haben wir nicht
aber borderless fullscreen sollte funktionieren du hast der kalf sagt er hat seine klima anlage
installiert das ist sehr nice das game ist immer so laut das muss man erstmal leiser
machen mixer
leute es geht schon hoch es geht schon hoch ja vielleicht vielleicht sollte ich mal kurz
nebenbei die nvidia overlay ausmachen
vielleicht bis sie viel overlay des guten
ok nice
guck hier overlay poggers funktioniert
ja ich gehe mal in den multiplayer game und schaue ob
shoot house 24 7 poggers das war es für mich also wir spielen jetzt nicht großartig will
einfach nur gucken das funktioniert
ja dörner bruder ich weiß auch nicht warum die das geld immer so laut machen ich hab
die vermutung ich bin aber nicht sicher ob das ob da was dran ist ich hab die vermutung
warum dies die audio settings nicht funktionieren ich glaube das ist eine anti cheat maßnahme
ich glaube die die verändern das game immer leicht von start zu start so dass wenn aus
das geld nicht mehr erkennt und deswegen sagt es ist neu neue applikation die mit maximaler
lautstärke gestartet wird das ist meine vermutung so klappt das overlay zeigt mal her
ich brauche mal eine bison muss meine bison klasse hier beste cpu gibt leute geht guck
mal hier 73 grad cpu gpu geht hoch excellent nice ja gleich tun das ist der typisch von
der waffe es funktioniert es funktioniert wenn ich raus gehe also keine andere guter
läuft das game ja weiter gpu 84 grad cpu 74 grad und dann haben wir call of duty gleich
mal aus monka es was ist denn hier los 30 milliarden gegner in dem game hast du wirklich legit
keine ahnung wo was herkommt also wir joppern gar nicht gerade des todes kann das sein wir
monka joppern gar nicht gerade ihr habt es ja mal im blick gpu cpu geht hoch das typischer
modern warfare todes so jetzt war modern warfare gleich mal aus ach so übrigens leute soll
ich euch ja was sagen oder ist ein wie toll der wie tollt geh weg wie toll piss dich alter
reload reload reloading gegner gegner what the fuck ok die rage quitten jetzt mal und
gucken dass die cpu und gpu temperatur runter geht rage quitt
runter spiel zu kurz fullscreen dafür dass das funktioniert muss das borderless borderless
fullscreen spielen wir können es mal ausprobieren wie es mit fullscreen aussieht aber es sollte
mit fullscreen rein von der logik her nicht funktionieren wie kann es denn auf einschlag
minus 10 grad runtergehen das geht doch schnell das fragt jede sekunde fragt es ab und innerhalb
von einer sekunde kann es schon 10 grad runtergehen sobald es halt keine leistung mehr zieht
das geht schon schnell mach lieber einen schwarzen raum um den um den text wir können das ausprobieren
gleich ob es im schwarzen raum besser aussieht ok ich schalte es jetzt mal in fullscreen
richtig echten fullscreen und dann sollte es von der idee her nicht funktionieren
ne seht ihr seht ihr leute das kann auch das kann auch eigentlich nicht funktionieren im
fullscreen warum geht warum geht mein gift auf allei
das darf da überhaupt nicht gehen kann das sein dadurch dass es irgendwie minimiert wird
und wieder ich glaube ich weiß woran das liegt das das liegt am minimieren gehe ich mal von
aus glaube das liegt da minimieren dass es dass es wahrscheinlich das gelb irgendwie
aus dem fullscreen raus wirft oder so ich habe keine aber das kann das das kann gar
nicht funktionieren also die die auferlehrgeschichte funktioniert mit dem windows quasi mit dem
desktop rendern zusammen also mit dem fenster über fenster rendern und exklusiver fullscreen
kann keine fenster weil es keine fenster gibt
ne im borderless fullscreen ist es nicht das habe ich ja gerade umgedreht und man sieht
auch wie lange es braucht wenn ich reinteppe also sprich wenn ich das jetzt hier anlasse
und gehe raus und gehe wieder rein dann sollte das bild wieder weg sein
mein bildschirm zeigt übrigens gerade nichts an guckle jetzt ist das bild weg das hat garantiert
was mit dem minimieren und maximieren hier zu tun wenn ich es nämlich ausplände dann
ist wieder da das ist das ist irgendeine geschichte dass das game dann aus dem fullscreen raus
geworfen wird oder so das kann kein echter fullscreen sein wäre das echter fullscreen
dann würde es das geht gar nicht das geht technisch nicht das ist echter fullscreen
ist dann wenn da fenster davor gerendert werden geht nicht
das können wir vergessen ja leute aber unser overlay tut echt gut
muss man sagen funktioniert wunderbar wir probieren es jetzt nochmal mit schwarzem
overlay zu lull also sagen wir anstatt white sagen wir jetzt mal hier black das besser
aussieht das muss ich mal zeigen ich glaube das ist besser ich glaube das ist
besser ich glaube mit schwarzem rand ist besser oder ich glaube das kommt besser kommt besser
raus die schrift ja ja ja auf jeden fall guck jetzt haben wir nämlich fullscreen jetzt
ist es weg also wir haben jetzt echt ein fullscreen wir schalten jetzt mal ein borderless fullscreen
um und dann ist es wieder da da ist es ja das sieht besser aus das sieht besser aus
noch mal kurz ins game rein das sieht mit schwarz jetzt besser aus
profi harzer ich habe da keine richtige erklärung für das hat was mit dem fenster minimieren
zu tun ich vermute mal dass wenn das fenster maximiert wird quasi ein anderes fenster
focus bekommt außer das spiel dass das winnows dann das game irgendwie aus dem exklusiven
fullscreen modus irgendwie raushaut und wenn man ins game fenster wieder reinklickt quasi
das wieder anschaltet was auch immer ergibt eigentlich wenig sinn hast du eigentlich
mal den simulierten fullscreen von winnows 10 ausprobiert das sieht doch aber leute
ohne scheiße sieht viel besser aus das overlay das overlay sieht viel besser aus mit mit
schwarz viel besser viel besser zu lesen als mit dem weißen drum herum viel besser
was ist laut meine güte jetzt habe ich gerade ein bisschen laut
ja wir können sie übertreiben also ich ich wollte ja eigentlich nur mal gucken wie man
sowas implementieren kann ja also sprich dass man dann jetzt noch 20.000 sachen dran optimieren
kann ist klar wunderbar ja das ist ein remake und man sieht auch an der cpu temperatur es
funktioniert das funktioniert so ein clusterfuck map aber ich bin begeistert wie gut das klappt
guckt euch an overlay am start wie liest du die werte aus ich kann es ja noch mal kurz
zeigen für alle die jetzt erst dabei gekommen sind aber mal zu also man könnte das mit
einem shortcut machen noch ich wollte es eigentlich was essen ich habe jetzt keine zeit das mit
dem shortcut noch zu machen also das mit dem shortcut ist kein allzu großes ding das haben
wir hier irgendwo auch gemacht wo machen wir das hier mit dem shortcut das mit dem shortcut
machen wir an anderer stelle wo man das mit dem shortcut was doch hier mit dem shortcut
das mit dem shortcut registrieren machen wir an anderer stelle mal gucken wie kompliziert
das war mit dem shortcut dann baue ich das vielleicht noch schnell ein dass sich der
chat freut nur für den chat wieder hier so ich muss das abgucken von meinem anderen
project hier wo ist es denn ich blick nicht mehr durch zumachen zumachen hier da wo könnten
wir das drin haben services desktop app service das klingt gut das ist das ist max big brain
hotkey hier big brain benahmung was für eine hotkey library verwenden wir da das da das
ist die hotkey library die wir verwenden genau ich erinnere mich an diese hotkey library
hier top ah ja wie ich die temperaturen auslese genau zeige ich dir hotkeys da zeige ich dir
und zwar die temperaturen lesen wir aus hier wie gesagt das ganze program ist ziemlich
klein ihr mit und zwar das ist eine library die sich libre hardware monitor nennt und
da gibt es dann eine libre hardware monitor lip die haben hier einfach eine referenz drauf
und können das verwenden das ist ziemlich geil dass das alles support nice so mal drauf
geschissen auf die shortcuts jetzt egal es funktioniert und das ist massiv poggers guckt
euch mal an wie doll das funktioniert unser overlay und nachdem ich jetzt es geschafft
hat mal wirklich in einem stream fast drei stunden was am stück zu machen ohne großartig
sidetracked zu werden gucken wir jetzt noch eine runde barbecue pit boys und ich esse
was jetzt haben wir hier peppered pork bacon butter burger excellent kikona oh der hört
sich schon ein bisschen corona mäßig an guckt euch an overlay poggers so ich esse jetzt
mal schnell was weil ich habe die ganze zeit schon was zu essen am start und habe erst
gesagt okay ich mache das erst fertig erstmal schön ordentlich das sound von denen hört
sich heute irgendwie kaputt an oder aber es wird richtig coconut style mal gucken ob die
anderen videos sich normal anhören ob das an meinem sound klickt lässt man sound irgendwie
im arsch mal kurz was checken das übliche weil es ja windows gerne umstellt geht windows
stellt das bei mir immer gerne um die sample rates ich weiß auch nicht warum geht nicht
okay dann ist doch richtig dann dann ist mein ohr wahrscheinlich einfach kaputt ist dein
temprogramm auch wenn gar sicher das ist für nix sicher also ich also ich garantiere
natürlich für nix ja also ich denke mal die meisten anti cheat programe dürften damit
okay sein weil es hijack kein prozess es hockt nix es ist einfach ein stink normales
overlay window so wie es halt viele mpx auch verwenden so wie es halt viele mpx auch verwenden
die
Der Browser-Sound ist komisch, das stimmt doch irgendwas nicht.
Das stimmt doch mit dem Browser-Sound nicht, das hört sich komplett verkehrt an.
Ne, das sind die Sound-Settings in dem Video, die haben irgendwie einen Kompressor falsch eingestellt oder so.
Seht ihr auch diese schwarze Linie hier Leute? Seht ihr in der Mitte diese schwarze Linie? Guckt mal hier. Wo kommt denn die her? Im Fullscreen ist sie weg. Hier ist sie wieder, guckt mal.
Magnifier, ich zeige es euch. Äh, da, seht ihr es hier?
Ne, aber ich habe es auch nicht so nicht leiser. Guckt mal. Ja doch, vielleicht ein bisschen.
Ich habe die gleichen Browser-Lautstärke wie immer. Das liegt diesmal an denen, ansonsten ist das nichts.
Ne, am Soundbooster liegt das nicht. Na wenigstens machen sie es heute richtig und es kommt keinerlei Gemüse drauf.
Boah, fuck, Alter. Hell yeah, Brother.
Ey, ich glaube gut schmecken tut das schon.
Boah, Alter, wie viel Pfeffer. Das ist ja eher Pepper-Burger.
Ey, ich meine schmecken tut das bestimmt richtig gut.
Ich wünsche mir jetzt auch einen geben.
Wie sie alles mit der Machete machen immer, oder Küchenbeil.
All you need now is a cold one, or two.
Oh, Martha, we miss you, girl.
Alright, we're just about ready to serve it. Those burgers are done, we'll just put some cheddar cheese on, or your favorite cheese, toast it up the buns, add what condiment you want.
Just a little bit of mayo, you do what you want. It's called pit master privilege.
Seh ich da Gemüse? Seh ich da sowas wie Gemüse?
Das ist aber nicht im Sinne des Erfinders, ja.
Oder Tomaten, na Tomaten zählen bei Burger nicht als Gemüse.
Ey, würde ich mir jetzt, ohne Scheiß, würde ich mir jetzt eins zu eins so reinhauen.
Ohne Spaß, Leute. Sofort weg wäre der.
Budget, was war das andere? Das muss ich jetzt auch noch mal gucken.
Budget, Roast Beef.
Das ist Sesambrötchen, rein Sesambrötchen und eine beziehungsweise halbierte, also zwei aufeinander Scheibe Nutella Brot, fertig.
Jetzt muss das, bei denen muss das noch so richtig pluten, ja.
Das wird da reingespritzt, alles.
Grillst du auch gerne selbst? Ja, allerdings dauert mir das meistens zu lang.
Wenn man wirklich ordentlich grillen will, braucht man auch ein bisschen Zeit, als wenn man die guten Sachen machen will.
Da bin ich, habe ich meistens keinen Bock drauf, mich da fünf Stunden an Grill zu holen.
Ah, fünf Stunden ist übertrieben, zwei Stunden.
Dieses Jahr wie das Silvester-Stream kann durchaus sein, ja.
Hört er jetzt, jetzt hört er sich normal an, jetzt übersteuert er nicht.
Jetzt versitzt er zu leise.
Ah, da wird Beef injectet.
Das Huhn wird da nächste Woche gegrillt.
Die Musik, die Musik, oh Alter.
Die Musik ist so richtig Hardcore-Kokone, Alter.
Ich will sehen, wo es gegrillt wird, wo wird es gegrillt.
Schon wieder Gemüse.
Genmanipulierter Riesenknoblauch.
Jetzt haben wir wieder ein bisschen mehr Beef-Große, und dann wackeln wir es.
Ich sage euch, wenn ihr Pfeffer-Rosen mögt, müsst ihr das aufschauen.
Wann wird dann gegrillt? Hier, hier wird gegrillt.
Die machen da immer echt für die halbe Fußballmannschaft Essen, oder was heißt für die halbe, für die ganze Fußballmannschaft.
Ich meine, da ist ja auch noch mal so ein Ding drin.
Aber denen sind es maximal zwei Personen.
Für zwei Mann reicht es gerade so.
Jetzt wird es advanced, Alter, jetzt wird es advanced.
Grill-Eye.
Man beachte, unser Auferlay läuft die ganze Zeit und funktioniert.
Woher das Auferlay? Das haben wir heute im Stream programmiert.
Den Quellkraut brauchst du nicht, das sind 30 Zeilen oder so. Ich kann es dir gleich nochmal zeigen, wenn ich fertig essen bin.
Aber es sieht gut aus. Sieht richtig gut aus, würde ich jetzt auch essen.
Dafür brauchst du aber echt Zeit. Das machst du nicht in einer halben Stunde auf dem Grill.
Der Friseur spielt komische Mobile Games.
Das ist ja so ein advanced Grill hier.
Boah, es sieht schon gut aus. Also muss man sagen, gut aussehen tut das.
Wie er immer lacht dazwischen.
Im Prinzip könnte er jedes Video mit so einem Soundboard machen.
Das andere gefällt mir besser. Das andere sieht viel knuspriger aus mit der Barbecue-Sauce.
Es kann durchaus sein, dass das geschmacklich nicer ist, aber das andere sieht erst mal besser aus.
Jetzt wird es nochmal extra gegrillt.
Ah, exzellent.
Das würde ich mir auch noch direkt reindrücken.
Erfohmer, das da oben ist in.NET, unser CPU-GPU-Temperatur-Overlay.
Warum tropft ihr immer von 70 Grad zu 72? Das weiß ich nicht.
Weil der Sensor das sagt.
Das ist die Durchschnittstemperatur über alle 6 Cores. Das kann schon sein, dass das ziemlich schwankt.
Wenn alle Kerne ausgelastet sind, ist es ziemlich konstant.
Da läuft es raus.
Ja, ich glaube, die machen auch beim Essen die Sounds. Die machen permanent immer die Sounds.
So wie ich mittlerweile auch RL schon in Twitch-Emotes spreche, reden die wahrscheinlich auch den ganzen Tag so.
Und wahrscheinlich ist es dumm.
Oh, das sieht echt gut aus. Das sieht echt gut aus. Mit der Barbecue-Sauce da drauf, das sieht echt gut aus.
Das würde ich am liebsten essen von den ganzen Sachen da.
Das würde ich mir jetzt richtig nochmal reinkloppen, das ganze Ding.
Erstmal Kilo Fleisch jetzt noch essen. Easy.
Ich weiß nicht, wie schwer das ist, was der da hat.
Oh, ich denke auch, es wäre besser gewesen, wenn die das mit einem scharfen Messer geschnitten hätten.
Ansonsten hat es total zerdrückt.
Erstmal schön alles rausgucken, dass da nichts mehr drin ist nachher.
So muss das sein.
Boah, das ist ein riesen Sandwich.
Das ist ja kein Sandwich, das ist ein riesen... Ach du Scheiße.
Was kommt denn alles drauf, Alter? Das kann doch keiner mehr essen danach.
Alter, das hab ich verschluckt.
Ich bin schon über mein Kabel da drüber gefahren, was ist das hier?
Wartet mal, irgendwie spackt mein Headset wieder.
Weil ich übers Kabel gefahren bin.
So, geht wieder.
Ich muss einfach nur ein bisschen Krach machen, dann geht's.
Achso, äh... Leute, auf was stand das noch mal vorher? Hier, 25, ne?
25 stand das die ganze Zeit.
Exzellent.
Alter, ich bin schon wieder über mein Kabel gefahren, das kann doch nicht sein.
Hau das.
Also, das ist eine riesen Portion, Alter.
Okay, Leute, hatte ich jetzt... Ich muss mal kurz in meine History reingucken.
Auf was hatte ich denn mein Mikro stehen?
Auf was hatte ich denn mein Mikro stehen eben vorher?
Hatte ich das hier auf 25 stehen oder hatte ich auf 30 stehen?
Schauen wir mal kurz.
Ja, Max ist gut.
Wo mache ich das denn jetzt?
Wo mache ich das jetzt hier? Ah, hier, hier.
Okay.
Postchamp.
Ja, auf Max, mach.
Okay, ja, ne.
Hier stand's.
Wobei, da habe ich noch wieder drauf eingestellt, ne?
Ja, okay, ne, passt.
Dann ist alles gut, dann habe ich es richtig eingestellt.
Porgös.
Ja, irgendjemand wollte vorher noch wissen, wie wir das machen mit dem Overlay.
Das ist alles, das ist der gesamte Source Code.
Also, es hält sich sehr in Grenzen.
Und wir benutzen dafür eine liebere Hardware-Monitor-Lib-DLL.
Das ist wohl eine.NET-Library für alle möglichen Hardware-Erkennungsgeschichten.
Wusste ich bis vor ein paar Stunden auch nicht, dass es die gibt.
Exzellent.
Ja.
Aber ich bin begeistert, wie gut das funktioniert mit dem Overlay.
Jetzt hätte ich echt nicht gedacht, dass das so gut klappt.
Ich meine, das ist natürlich jetzt nicht besser als jetzt hier irgendwie das Nvidia-Overlay.
Aber es ging halt darum, dass man mal rauskriegt, wie man sowas einbaut.
Der Vorteil von diesem Nvidia-Overlay und von den ganzen anderen offiziellen Sachen,
so MSI Afterburner, was gibt es denn da noch?
Alles FRAPS, verwendet aber keiner mehr.
Die ganzen Geschichten sind natürlich diese Programme sind Whitelist in Anti-Cheat-Geschichten.
Und sie bieten direkt die Möglichkeit, auch in Fullscreen-Anwendungen sich rein zu hooken.
Das macht mein Overlay natürlich nicht.
Aber das war ja überhaupt nicht der Ziel heute.
Das Ziel heute war einfach mal zu schauen, wie man sowas basteln könnte.
Ja, Michael-50-Spiel, ja, mach's gut.
Also wenn man sowas verwendet, kann durchaus sein, dass das irgendeinen Anti-Cheat anschlägt.
Das sollte nicht, weil ich meine, ein Overlay an sich ist ja kein Cheat im eigentlichen Sinne.
Aber man weiß nie, wie empfindlich die Anti-Cheat-Sachen sind.
Und wenn man ein Overlay hat, was nicht Whitelisted ist, dann kann es durchaus sein, dass das ausspuckt.
Aber das kann eh keiner verwenden, weil ich das nirgends hochladen werde.
Es war ja einfach nur ein Test, wie man es machen könnte.
Ja, Leute, das war's für heute.
Wir sind fertig.
Das war mal tatsächlich ein recht produktiver Stream.
Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream.
Ich hoffe, euch hat's gefallen.
Mal gucken, weil ich wieder am Start bin.
Letzter Zeit ja relativ oft.
Licky Brain, schön, wenn's dir gefallen hat.
In letzter Zeit bin ich ja recht oft am Start.
Vielleicht bin ich gleich schon wieder morgen da.
Mal schauen.
Weiß ich nicht genau.
Vielleicht mach ich auch mal einen Tag Pause und mach dann irgendwie weiter.
Ja, das war's. Bis dann. Macht's gut.
Das war's für heute.
Danke fürs Zuschauen.
Tschüss.